Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass, es ist wieder soweit. Wir blicken auf die internationalen Ligen der Männer, die Ligatur ist zurück. Ich weiß, dass ihr euch genauso freut wie ich. Und deswegen lasst uns jetzt gleich starten hier mit Rasenfunk Kurzpass 243. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und hallo und herzlich willkommen an meine geliebte Ligaturen Runde. Ich begrüße zu meiner Linken in den Headquarters Christian Bernhardt. Hallo Christian.
Hallo Max, hallo in die Runde.
Er ist extrem euphorisch, das kann ich euch sagen. Genauso wie Alex Truica. Hallo Alex. Und dann haben wir noch am Telefon zugeschaltet, wie bei einer Außenwette bei Wetten das. Alexi Menuge, hallo Alexi. Schön, dass ihr alle da seid. Es war eine zu lange Pause. Ich weiß es, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ihr habt es mir auch gespiegelt. Aber damit ist es jetzt vorbei. Wir haben große Pläne für die Ligatur. Jetzt wird sie regelmäßiger erscheinen. Ich will noch nicht ankündigen, in welchem Rhythmus, denn der muss sich jetzt erstmal bei uns allen einspielen. Aber es wird einen Rhythmus geben und es wird nicht wieder so lange zur nächsten Sendung dauern. Wie immer der kurze Hinweis, der Rasenfunk ist und bleibt werbe- paywall und sponsorenfrei. Alles, was wir hier machen und auch die Honorare, die wir unseren Gästen zahlen, die finanzieren sich ausschließlich aus eurer freiwilliger Unterstützung auf rasenfunk.de slash supportersclub. Da könnt ihr erfahren, wie ihr uns unterstützen könnt. Und ein Hinweis, wir sind jetzt eine GmbH und unsere Konto-Verbindung hat sich verändert. Das heißt, wenn ihr noch einen laufenden Dauerauftrag habt, dann geht unbedingt auf rasenfunk.de slash Konto, denn alles Geld, was auf das alte Konto ankommt, das können wir nicht verwenden, um Rechnungen für den Rasenfunk zu bezahlen, weil wir uns verändert haben. Wenn euch interessiert, warum wir das gemacht haben, dazu gibt es eine eigene Schlusskonferenz. Frank und ich haben da ausführlich darüber gesprochen, warum wir jetzt so was wie eine GmbH sind. Und es fühlt sich auch immer noch komisch an. Aber gut, Christian kann bezeugen, es hat sich hier nichts verändert. Kein vergoldeter Boden seit…
Also die Marmor, die Marmor-Fließen habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Ja, da gibt es Lieferprobleme. Das ist natürlich der einzige Grund. Gut, wir wollen loslegen und mal auf die internationalen Top-Ligen gucken. Wir beschäftigen uns jetzt mit Serie A, Ligue 1 und La Liga und Premier League. Werdet ihr in einem eigens aufgezeichneten Segment im Anschluss noch hören können. Ich würde sagen, Alex, lass doch mal mit La Liga beginnen. Da hast du uns unter anderem Valencia als Thema mitgebracht. Und als ich auf die Tabelle geguckt habe, was ich ehrlicherweise schon eine Weile nicht mehr gemacht habe, ich habe mich auch schlecht dabei gefühlt, da wusste ich dann schlagartig, warum Platz 18, 20 Punkte nur aktuell auf einem Abstiegsplatz, nur man hat einen Punkt Rückstand noch nach oben. Also da gibt es noch einen Anknüpfungspunkt. Aber wenn ich mir die letzten sechs Spiele angucke, dann sehe ich da fünf Niederlagen und ein Unentschieden. Was ist da schon wieder bei Valencia los?
Ja, das Gleiche eigentlich wie immer. Es ist sogar noch ein bisschen schlimmer, als du es aufgezeichnet hast. Sie sind sieben Spiele ohne Sieg und haben in den letzten 13 Spielen nur einmal gewinnen können, Valencia. Dementsprechend in der Abstiegszone drin. Es sieht ganz, ganz übel aus. Und natürlich wurde der Trainer entlassen. Logisch, was man da so macht, als Großverein als Traditionsclub. Genaro Gattuso wurde entlassen. Dann gab es mal wieder einen Interim-Coach. Voro hat das zum siebten Mal gemacht. Das muss irgendein Rekord sein. Also so die gute Seele des Vereins, der immer wieder Co-Trainer ist und sonst irgendwie aushilft. Auch mal Sportdirektor zwischendurch zum siebten Mal als Interim-Coach.
So wie Friedhelm Funkel. Nee, wie Pardaler bei Hertha eigentlich, muss man sagen.
Ja, der hat noch ein bisschen Luft.
Der war schon bald zum vierten Mal aushilft. Na ja gut, ich will jetzt hier nicht.
Kann auch kommen. Kann auch kommen, genau. Und da wurde auch schon wieder nicht kommuniziert, ob er jetzt nur Interim-Coach ist oder ob er bis zum Saisonende bleibt. Also, mach einfach mal, hilf uns ein bisschen. Und nachdem sie da die zwei, drei Spiele unter ihm natürlich auch verloren haben, wurde jetzt ein neuer Trainer geholt. In Rubenbaracher kehrt eine Vereinslegende zurück. Den kennt ja der eine oder andere von euch als Spieler damals. Zu den besseren Zeiten von Valencia war er ja ein Haudegen im Mittelfeld. So würde ich jetzt mal formulieren. Zwischen 1999 und 2010 hat er rund 360 Partien für Valencia absolviert. Der soll jetzt Valencia vor dem Abstiegs retten, aber ganz ehrlich, so richtig Hoffnung macht diese Personalie nicht.
Warum? Also, Identifikation und so ist ja dann sicherlich da, aber wegen fehlender Vorerfahrung oder?
Genau, ich wollte gerade sagen, Identifikation und so wäre ja ganz schön, nur der hat keinerlei Erstliga-Erfahrung, der Kollege Baracha, und hat nur in der 2. Liga gecoacht, reinweise Vereine, aber immer sehr, sehr erfolglos. Also auch nicht ein Verein irgendwie zu einem Aufstieg geführt oder so wurde bei jeder Station entlassen, also ich zähle nur mal die Stationen auf. Nachdem er bei Valencia aufgehört als Spieler war Jugendtrainer und Co-Trainer und dann ging es zum FC Elche, eine Saison, da wurde er entlassen, bei Rayo Vaekano, eine Saison, da wurde er entlassen, bei Sporting Gijón, eine Saison, wurde entlassen und bei Tenerife war auch eine Saison und wurde auch entlassen. Jeweils 2. Liga, jeweils ist die Mannschaft irgendwie in den Keller gerutscht gegen den Abstieg, hat irgendwie 10 Spiele oder ähnliches nicht gewonnen und da wurde jedes Mal entlassen. Auch bei Saragossa war glaube ich nicht mal eine Saison, also sogar nur ein paar Monate. Also du merkst schon, das macht irgendwie nicht so richtig Hoffnung diese Personalie oder anders gesagt, das ist ziemlich verzweifelt, was Valencia da macht. Also man holt ja nicht jemanden, der irgendwie Hoffnung gibt oder der erfahren ist, sondern den Nächsten besten, weil es keinen besseren gibt.
Ja, aber Moment mal, also im US-Sport würde man sagen, die tanken, die wollen einen guten Draft pickern. Ich denke, das können wir ausschließen.
Du bist noch unterm Eindruck der Superbowls, ich merke schon.
Ja, aber das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn. Also man hat den Interimstrainer, der war schon sieben Mal da. Und wenn man ihn ein sechstes und ein siebtes Mal zurückholt, dann war das ja jetzt nicht ganz, ganz schlimm, was der als Interimstrainer gemacht hat. Und er war halt einfach da. Also offensichtlich ist es wie Matarazzo bei Hoffenheim. Der hat eh schon in der Nähe gewohnt. Na komm, dann machst du es halt jetzt bei uns. Aber warum holt man dann jemanden, der quasi an bei allen vorherigen Stationen entlassen wurde? Und dass man entlassen wird, ist ja nichts besonderes als Trainer. Aber dass man früh entlassen wird, also nicht mal eine Saison schafft?
Naja, du hast es ja schon angesprochen. Identifikation schaffen, den Verein kennen. Also das sind so die offenbar die Grundtugenden und Werte, die hier im Fokus standen bei der Anstellung. Also nicht, es sind keine sportlichen Gründe, denn er hatte keinerlei sportlichen Erfolg bei 5 Stationen in der 2. Liga. Sondern es sind halt nostalgische Gründe, sondern nicht mal oder verzweifelte Gründe. Du bist so verzweifelt, dass du sagst, ich hole irgendeinen, der den Verein kennt, der hier eine Legende ist, auch um die Fans zu besänftigen, denn die sind sehr, sehr aufgebracht. Kann man sich natürlich vorstellen, wenn es beim Traditionsclub grundsätzlich nicht gut läuft, dann ist es immer ein bisschen hitzig außenrum. Aber bei Valencia ist die Sache ja nochmal anders gelegen, denn Peter Lim ist ja der Investor, der Präsident, der Besitzer des Vereins. Der macht sich ja gar keine Fans und Freunde im Umfeld, seitdem er den Verein übernommen hat. Und es gab auch lautstarke Proteste zuletzt, mal wieder, nicht zum ersten Mal, dass die Fans auf die Barrikaden bzw. auf die Straße gehen. Und zwar buchstäblich, wortwörtlich auf die Straße, nämlich vor einem Spiel, blieb das Stadion leer, weil alle draußen gegen Peter Lim protestierten. Also da ist wirklich einiges im Argen bei Valencia. Und dementsprechend glaube ich, ist diese Anstellung von Baracha auch so ein bisschen eine Besänftigung der Fans, dass man eben einen alten Fansmann, einen Veteran, eine Vereinslegende zurückholt, um auch die Fans ein bisschen zu befrieden. Denn aktuell ist Chaos und Krise pur und Richtung 2. Liga geht es, wie die Tabelle ja zeigt.
Und funktioniert das deiner Meinung nach, oder sehen die Fans das so wie du? Eher hoffnungslos?
Ja gut, er hat jetzt noch kein Spiel geleitet. Man muss jetzt natürlich erst abwarten, wie sich das entwickelt. Das ist jetzt natürlich schwer zu prognostizieren, aber jetzt allein auf dem Papier, wie gesagt, wenn einer nur in der 2. Liga war und da auch nicht einen Verein mehr als ein Jahr betreute und auch nicht überhaupt irgendwie erfolgreich war. Ich glaube, mit einem Verein, mit RAIO, hat er die Playoffs erreicht. Also es gibt ja Aufstiegs-Playoffs in der 2. Liga. Ist da aber gescheitert. Das war quasi so deine erfolgreichste Saison. Also auch da nicht mal das erreicht, was sich RAIO erhofft, nämlich über die Playoffs aufsteigen. Aber einfach nur die Playoffs erreichen.
Da waren auch nur für 13 Spiele.
Ja, das war das Erfolgreichste. Ansonsten wirkt, wie gesagt, ständig im Abstiegs- oder im Mittelmaß gedümpelt und immer wieder rein weiße Spiele am Stück nicht gewonnen und dann entlassen worden. Also es macht einfach sportlich keine Hoffnung, dass so jemand jetzt in der ersten Liga Erfolg hat, wenn er ja nicht mal in der zweiten Liga mit fünf Vereinen auch nur annähernd irgendwie was Erfolgreiches aufbauen konnte. Das ist jetzt meine nüchtern sportliche Betrachtung. Aber klar kann man sagen, jemand, der einen Verein kennt, hat da vielleicht einen anderen Zugang zum Dressing-Room, zu den Spielern, zur Kabine, zu den Fans, zur Öffentlichkeit, zu den Pressevertretern, keine Ahnung, dass er halt so irgendwie da Synergien schafft oder dass er da irgendwie eine Aufbruchstimmung erzeugt, damit sie da unten rauskommen. Das kann natürlich auch sein, das bleibt abzuwarten. Aber rein mit Blick aufs Technische macht mir das nicht viel Hoffnung.
Aufbruchstimmung erzeugen, weil man Vereinslegend ist. So wie einst Niko Kovac beim FC Bayern.
Der war ein bisschen erfolgreicher bei Frankfurt vorher, oder?
Das ist ja genau das. Ja, das stimmt. Das ist das total falsche Beispiel. Mich würde interessieren, wie es in den anderen Ligen ist. Christian, kannst du dich erinnern an einen ähnlichen Trainer-Neuzugang, der quasi so schwierig ist? Oder könnte man sich das überhaupt in der Serie A vorstellen? Alexi, du darfst das gleich für Frankreich auch beantworten.
Das ist in der Serie A schon zuletzt immer wieder so, weil der Name Gattuso ja gerade ein aktuelles Beispiel ist. Es gibt in Italien schon einige der großen Namen, gerade von dieser 2006er Weltmeister-Mannschaft. Es sind hier einige im Trainergeschäft. Da sind auch einige vielleicht ein bisschen früher zu einem Serie A-Verein gekommen. Das schon. Aber mit so einem Hintergrund, mit so einem Traditionsverein und in so einer schwierigen Situation – weil wir reden jetzt ja nicht, wenn Valencia vielleicht 11. ist und sagt, die sind enttäuscht, weil sie nicht Richtung Europa Cup schielen – dann ist das ja eine Sache, aber das steckt mit in den Abstiegskampf. Und das ist, glaube ich, schon noch mal was existenziell anderes. Also nein, in jüngerer Vergangenheit, so ein Konkretes Beispiel kann ich mich nicht erinnern.
Alexi, gibt es was in der Ligue 1, was vergleichbar wäre?
Also in den letzten Jahren gab es ein ähnliches Beispiel wie Valencia, aber ich hätte noch eine Frage an Alex. Was ist mit Cavani los? Ist er nicht als Retter gesehen? Ist sein Zenit schon wie damals in Paris längst überschritten oder kann er noch die Mannschaft im Platz nachher sichern?
Er ist der erfolgreichste Torschütze mit. Habe ich jetzt nicht ganz auf dem Schirm. Ich glaube, sechs Saison-Toren. Ist jetzt nicht so viel, aber es sind ja trotzdem die meisten in der Mannschaft. Also er ist ja im fortgeschrittenen Alter. Viel mehr kann er ja da nicht machen in einer einfach sehr schlecht funktionierenden Mannschaft. Ich meine, du bist ja nicht ohne Grund drittletzter der Tabelle 18er und hast in 21 Spielen nur fünf Siege geholt und auch nur 26 Tore geschossen. Da kann auch ein Veteran im Sturm nicht so viel machen, wenn da einfach in der Mannschaft wenig funktioniert. Ich habe es ja vorhin vorgelesen, sieben Spiele ohne Sieg und in 13 Spielen nur einen Sieg geholt. Das spricht ja eher dafür, dass es nicht nur an den Toren mangelt, sondern auch daran, überhaupt Torschancen herauszuspielen. Das ist natürlich das Hauptproblem vieler Mannschaften in der Liga, dass wenig Tore geschossen werden, wenig Torschancen herausgespielt werden. Aber Valencia hat sich da unter Gattuso zuletzt auch sehr, sehr schwer getan. Das war teilweise wirklich unansehnlicher Fußball. Sie sind komplett ideenlos in den letzten Wochen, ja Monaten, muss man ja sagen. Da war ja die WM dazwischen, die hat ja für eine große Pause gesorgt. Also sie tun sich einfach wirklich sehr, sehr schwer, vernünftig gut Fußball zu spielen und Torschancen herauszuspielen. Und dann ist Cavani natürlich sehr, sehr abhängig von eben diesen Sachen. Und wenn das nicht klappt, dann kann auch ein Top-Stürmer da vorne drin wenig ausrichten.
Fünf Tore, ein Assist hat er bisher. Also eher durchwachsene Bilanz, würde ich sagen. Ich würde sagen, wir bleiben bei der schlechten Stimmung und machen gleich in Frankreich weiter, Alexi. Und da hast du ein Thema mit guter Stimmung und eins mit schlechter Stimmung. Ich möchte über Olympique Lyon sprechen und alle Kennerinnen und Kenner wissen jetzt schon, schlechte Stimmung. Lyon versinkt im Niemandsland. 35 Punkte hat man aktuell, liegt auf Rang 9. Damit hat man schon 6 Punkte Rückstand auf die Europa League und auf Champions League usw. Lohnt es sich vielleicht gar nicht zu rechnen, denn da sind es schon 12 Punkte. Was ist los in Lyon? Wir haben schon oft über Lyon gesprochen. Wir erinnern uns natürlich auch noch an das alte Lyon. Ist es vielleicht auch ein Problem, dass so Dudes wie ich, die immer nur so alle paar Wochen drauf gucken, sich immer an Juninho usw. erinnern und es bringt da niemanden weiter? Da haben wir ja auch genügend Beispiele in der Bundesliga. Stimmt.
Der Sinkt-in-Niemandsland, weil man hat das Gefühl, diese Mannschaft ist ein bisschen wie Füge hier und dort oben, mal lange oben und jetzt langsam nach unten. Das ist auch in Deutschland vergleichbar. Schalke, Hamburg, Hertha. Das irgendwann wirst du für deine schlechte Arbeit bestraft. Und irgendwann kommt der Abstieg. Also nicht in dieser Saison bei Lyon, das ist klar. Aber wenn sie weitermachen, dann sehe ich entweder, der da vorbei läuft, weil die Entwicklung macht Angst. Es gibt irgendwelche Baustellen, etliche strategische Fehler von den Verantwortlichen. Der Boss, Jean-Michel Olaß oder noch Boss, ist weit über 70 und hat schon seit zehn Jahren nichts mehr im Griff. Er spricht lieber von den Champions-League-Kriumpfen seiner Frauenmannschaft und vergisst aber, dass die Herrenmannschaft schlechte Arbeit liefert, die jetzt noch die Könnung mit dem Bekauf an einen amerikanischen Investor gegeben hat. John Texter, der auch schon Botafogo hat, aber auch Aktionsanteile an Crystal Palace. Dort gibt es eher kritische Stimmen an ihm, dass er nicht so der seriöseste Geschäftsmann ist. Auch in Lyon hat sich der Deal hinausgezögert. Jetzt hat man den Deal unter Dach und Pfarr gebracht, aber man weiß nicht, in welche Richtung. Jetzt hat man im Winter einige Stammspieler entgehen lassen, auch aus finanziellen Gründen. Mit Tokoekombi nach Rennes, mit Fevre nach Lorient, mit Tete nach Leicester City. Man hätte auch sehr, sehr gern John Boateng losgeraubt, aber ihn will keiner mehr haben und er fühlt sich in Lyon sehr, sehr gut. Da gibt es echt einfach die geilsten Restaurants der Welt. Und deswegen ist es schwer, da weiterzukommen. Es ist schon Boateng das Beispiel dieser Lyon-Niederdange. Er sitzt auf der Bank, spielt im Durchschnitt drei bis vier Minuten. Man sagt von den Lyon-Kollegen, also die Journalisten, die Lyon verfolgen tagtäglich, dass Boateng zum Beispiel nur eine Stunde pöperlich mithalten kann. Und das ist schon erschreckend, dass so ein bedienter Spieler, der so viele Reicheits in seiner Karriere nicht mehr in der Lage ist, da mitzuhalten, oder an die Klion, der gerade, wie du sagst, Acht oder neunte in der Tabelle ist.
Aber spielt denn da auch eine Rolle, was jetzt hier vor Gericht gegen Jerome Boateng so diskutiert wurde, dabei, dass er nicht spielt, oder hat es rein sportliche Gründe? Also wird es auch thematisiert, dass es ja eine Verurteilung wegen häuslicher Gewalt gibt und jetzt quasi dazu jetzt noch Folgeprozesse anstehen?
Das spielt gar keine Rolle. Zwar wussten die Lyon-Verantwortlichen nicht, als Jerome nach Lyon kam, dass er vor Gericht muss. Das war, glaube ich, ein Tatsache gespürt, aber es sind sie aus dem Himmel gefallen. Waren die Verantwortlichen empört über diese Tatsache, dass er vor Gericht muss von Menschen. Die wussten nichts davon. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie ihn geholt hätten, hätten sie das vorher gewusst. Laurent Blanc ist auch kein Blinder. Er war Frankreichs Nationaltrainer, PSG-Trainer, selbst Europameister, als Vizepräsident der französischen Nationalmannschaft. Er weiß, wie Fußball läuft, auch wenn er jetzt sechs Jahre komplett raus war. Er hat gesehen, dass Boateng zwar erfahren ist, die Mannschaft führen kann, aber jetzt hat er Dejan Lovren geholt im Winter. Das ist auch für Boateng ein Schlag ins Gesicht. Also sportlich kommt Boateng einfach nicht weiter und man geht sich im Sommer trennen, weil sein Fett halt ausläuft und dann wird er komplett auf, oder er geht auf einen anderen Kontinent, aber er kann einfach in Europa nicht mehr mithalten, wenn schon der SR Alltag sich mit ihm beschäftigt jetzt im Winter, dann ist das schon für ihn ein schlechtes Fessen.
Das klingt überhaupt nicht gut. Vor allem, wenn du sagst, der Präsident konzentriert sich eher auf die Erfolge des Frauenteams, dann kann man da an der Stelle nochmal kurz darauf hinweisen, dass das Jahre Björg Gunners vom Frauenteam vor wenigen Wochen offen gelegt hat bei The Athletic, wie wirklich schäbig sich der Verein ihr gegenüber verhalten hat, als sie schwanger wurde im laufenden Betrieb. Sie musste ihre Gehaltszahlungen einklagen. Da reden wir jetzt nicht über mehrere Millionen, sondern wenn ich richtig informiert bin, waren es 80.000 Euro, die jetzt ein Gericht zugestanden hat. Da hat sich der Verein ganz fürchterlich verhalten. Auf was kann man als Präsident stolz sein, wenn man den Frauenfußball fördern will? Ich weiß schon, dass die Frauen von Lyon viel erfolgreicher sind als die Männer aktuell. Aber da scheint mir viel im Argen zu liegen bei Lyon ganz generell.
Er ist der Spieler aller Zeiten in der Geschichte von Olympique Lyon. Aber als Sportdirektor hat er es einfach nicht drauf gehabt. Er hat auch betont beim Präsidenten, ich will eher Trainer werden und nicht Sportdirektor. So ging es schnell zu Ende eigentlich. Jetzt gab es immer wieder nicht nur Reibungen, sondern auch böse Konflikte und Provokationen in den Medien in Frankreich. Geninho aus Brasilien gibt bei einem französischen Radiosender immer wieder seinen Sens zu Lyon, aber nie positiv, das ist klar. Er ist auch nicht mehr gern in Lyon. Der beste Spieler aller Zeiten wird dermaßen kritisch beäugt bei den Vereinsposten. Denn bei den Sens geht Geninho nach wie vor als Gott. Sein Name wird bei jedem Heimspiel gesungen. Ehrlich? Das ist auch ein Affront gegenüber den Verantwortlichen. Man will auch, dass Olaß endlich mal in Rente geht. Aber er hat immer gesagt, sobald Lyon nur die Heermannschaft Europapokalsieger wird, wird er wohl nie schaffen. Man muss also nie kapieren, dass es unter seiner Leitung nicht funktionieren wird. Auch wenn Lyon, aus der positiven Note zum Abschluss dieses Themas, aus der nächsten Saison europalich spielen könnte, denn man steht im Ziel des Pokals, das Finale Heimspiel gegen Gründobl, zweitlich ist er so machbar.
Okay, also könnte es vielleicht über den Pokal noch klappen, mit den Europacup-Titel. Ein alter Mann, der nicht loslassen kann und seinen Verein ruiniert. Da frage ich jetzt nicht, ob wir das in der Liga und Serie A aussehen, weil wir so viel Zeit haben, glaube ich nicht.
Übrigens, wenn ich dazwischengerätschen darf, die Metapher oder der Vergleich des HSVs, da muss ich auch an Valencia denken. Also das passt, glaube ich, ganz gut. Ein Traditionsverein, der dem Abstieg entgegenrumpelt, weil er vom Chaos umgriffen ist oder das Chaos hat den Verein im Griff, was auf den HSV nochmals zugetroffen ist. Das passt irgendwie auch auf Valencia, weil Alex ja den HSV genannt hatte.
Ja, das habe ich mir tatsächlich auch notiert.
Da gibt es ein paar Parallelen tatsächlich. Wenn ein Verein so lange im Chaos steckt, immer wieder Trainerwechsel und grausames Management und Spieler werden verkauft und sind verunsichert, dann ist das so ein Strudel, der kann dann den Abstieg münden. Sie HSV.
Oje, oje, die armen HSV-Fans. Sogar sie hören unbedarft eine Ligatur und dann kommt wieder dieser HSV-Vergleich. Aber es sieht ja gerade gut aus und wir drücken die Daumen. Das wissen ja die HSV-Fans. Hoffentlich inzwischen habe ich ja schon oft genug hier betont. Dann lasst uns mal in die Serie A blicken und wir bleiben jetzt einfach total negativ, damit wir dann positiv enden können. Deswegen, Christian, müssen wir mit Milan starten. Da lief es so mittel?
Ja, also mittel ist nett ausgedrückt, aber es gibt jetzt was Aktuelles sehr Freuliches. Ganz kurz noch zuvorhin, mir ist, weil wir verdiente Spieler als Trainer, es gibt in Italien gerade ein ganz frisches Beispiel, Daniele De Rossi. Der hat jetzt seine erste Station bei SPAL in der 2. Liga. Er ist da eingestiegen und ist jetzt nach wenigen, nicht vielen Wochen entlassen worden. Also so viel zum Thema. Da reden wir zwar 2. Liga und klar, Daniele De Rossi ist keine SPAL-Legende, aber da sieht man, es ist halt oft nicht einfach am Anfang. SPAL ist jetzt auch unten reingerutscht und dann haben sie sich dazu entschieden. Also über De Rossi sind viele überzeugt, dass der einen guten Trainerweg gehen wird, aber jetzt am Anfang war halt diese Aufgabe dann auch für ihn zu ungemütlich.
Aber das ist ungewöhnlich, dass man ihn in Italien früh entlassen wird. Das kennt man gar nicht aus der Serie A.
Shots fired. Aber ich sag mal so Legenden, die mal gute Trainer werden könnten und sich aber schwer tun, da kann man auch mal Miro Klose fragen, wie es gerade so läuft im Alltag. Also das ist durchaus – es ist halt nicht so einfach, wie es von außen aussieht.
Und jetzt stell dir vor, die Bayern wären im Abstiegskampf und würden Miro Klose holen, nachdem der nur im Alltag und sonst wo rumgedümpelt ist.
Also ich bin ein riesen Miro Klose-Fan. Vielleicht bin ich da aber auch positiv bei. Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass der ein schlechter Trainer ist. Das ist natürlich Quatsch. Jeder kann ein schlechter Trainer sein. Aber ja, ach ja, wir hätten zumindest – da würde endlich mal wieder über die Bayern berichtet werden, weil ich meine, das geht denen ja so richtig ab. Naja, gut, aber Ironie-Modus aus und Milan-Modus an. Also eine positive Sache gibt es. Ich glaube, du möchtest mit der Champions League die Wäsche setzen.
Ja, ne, also ich würde – fangen wir mal, wir müssen schon mit dem Januar anfangen. Also was da passiert ist, ist mit Milan schwer zu erklären. Milan hat dann, muss man sich mal vorstellen, Milan hat im Januar so viele Gegentore kassiert, nämlich 18, wie zuletzt in den 1920er Jahren. Also es gab auf knapp 100 Jahre nicht mehr so einen schlechten Defensivmonat. Das ging los 0-3 gegen Inter im Supercup, dann gab es ein 0-4 gegen Lazio in der Liga, dann gab es ein 2-5 zu Hause gegen Sassuolo. Alles in einer Reihe, es gab das Pokal aus. Also Milan ist wirklich implodiert, wirklich auch aus dem Nichts. Das war wirklich extrem schwer zu erklären. Und dann kam auch noch das Liga-Durbit, jetzt haben sie 0-1 verloren. So, das war die Ausgangslage. Dieses Liga-Durbit war auch deshalb bemerkenswert, weil im Zuge dieser kompletten defensiven Zusammenbruchs Piorli komplett von seinem System weggegangen ist. Das 4-2-3-1 hat Milan und Piorli zum Meister letztes Jahr gemacht, diese mutige, intensive Mannschaft. Und er hat auf Dreierkette umgestellt. Zum ersten Mal seit mehr als vier Jahren bei Milan. Er hat gesagt, es funktioniert überhaupt nicht, ich muss was ändern. Was daraus folgte, war eine erste Hälfte gegen Inter, die Wahnsinn war, weil Milan einfach nicht mehr zu erkennen war. Die sind nur noch hinterhergelaufen. Du hast ihnen die Verunsicherung in jedem Spiel am Gesicht angesehen. Die haben nur versucht, die Räume zuzustellen. Sie haben dieses Spiel an 0-1 verloren. In der zweiten Hälfte haben sie sich ein bisschen reingefightet. Aber in der ersten Hälfte gab es keinen Torschuss. Also nicht mal Abschluss. Sie hatten, glaube ich, gefühlt 27 Prozent Ballbesitz. Also all das, für das Milan stand unter Piolli, war weg. Man konnte sich einzelne Spieler anschauen. Theo Hernandez, Leao, teilweise auf der Bank. All diese wichtigen Spieler, die letztes Jahr entscheidend zum Scudetto waren, alle komplett verunsichert. Ich muss sagen, ich habe lange nachgedacht. Ich habe keine Spitzenmannschaft in den letzten Jahren in ganz Europa vor, ist mir eingefallen, die wirklich innerhalb so weniger Wochen komplett der Verunsicherung zum Opfer gefallen ist.
Dortmund unter Peter Boss, aber das ist schon eine Weile her.
Okay, siehst du, das ist gut. Ich habe echt lange nachgedacht, weil das kam wirklich im Januar. Sie haben noch gegen die Roma 2-0 geführt. Und dann kassieren sie spät in den letzten Minuten zwei Gegentore. Und ab da ist sozusagen alles den Bach runtergegangen. So, das war die Ausgangsposition. Und jetzt aber hatten wir ja vorgestern dieses Champions-League-Achtelfinal-Hinspiel gegen Tottenham. Und sie gewinnen es 1-0, haben auch wenige Tage davor in der Liga auch gegen Torino. Das war auch in dieser Befreiungsschlag auch 1-0 gewonnen. Weiterhin mit der Dreierkette. Also Pio Ali hat jetzt auch erstmal gesagt, wir probieren jetzt einfach mal Stabilität reinzukriegen. Und gegen Tottenham war das jetzt wirklich – sie haben jeden Zweikampf angenommen. Also diese Intensität gegen den Ball war auf jeden Fall wieder da. Tottenham hat echt nicht viel gehabt. Und ja, ich weiß, Tottenham ist jetzt im Moment auch nicht in der überragendsten Form. Aber trotzdem, aus Milan's Sicht, dass du dann in so einem wichtigen Spiel – Pio Ali hat gemeint, das war das bisher wichtigste Spiel seiner Karriere – also dass du dann da schaffst, zu Null zu spielen gegen Tottenham. Kjær und Kane, die haben sich ein – ich nenne es mal – Intensivfestuell über 90 Minuten geliefert. Malik Csau, den müssen wir erwähnen, der junge Deutsche, der von Schalke kam. Überragendes Spiel gemacht gegen Tottenham, hat auch davor gegen Torino eben gespielt. Also ist da jetzt erstmal reingekommen, fühlt sich in der Dreierkette wohl, hat es sogar fast das 2-0 gemacht in der zweiten Hälfte. Riesen Kopfball-Chance. Aber ja, echt eine total spannende Entwicklung bei mir und ich bin gespannt, wie es jetzt weitergeht. Ich glaube schon, dass gerade dieser Sieg jetzt gegen Tottenham nochmal einen enormen Selbstbewusstseinsschub gegeben hat, weil man davon nicht vergessen, es fehlen immer noch extrem wichtige Leute. Mike Meignan, der Torhüter, extrem wichtig, der in all dieser löchrigen Defensive in dieser Phase noch mehr gefehlt hat als vielleicht andere Spieler. Tomori verletzt, Benazir hat auch noch verletzt gefehlt. Also es scheint wieder bei mir ein Aufwärts zu gehen, aber wirklich extrem interessant, wie sie da wirklich, wie Piolli komplett weg von seiner Linie ist und jetzt versucht, über einen anderen Weg wieder sein altes Milan wiederzufinden.
Und wie wird das begleitet? Denn wir haben ja schon öfter mal darüber gesprochen, dass der Sportjournalismus in Italien taktischer ist und analytischer.
Sehr kritisch. Also diese erste Hälfte gegen Inter, da wurde Milan so zu Rissen wie lange nicht mehr. Weil eben alle, weil viele gesagt haben auch zum Beispiel Arigosaki, gemeint, hey, Piolli ist komplett von seiner Identität weggegangen. Also all das, was Milan davor ausgezeichnet hat, war nicht mehr zu sehen. Also es war extrem kritisch. Wurde wirklich auch von den TV-Experten und so, alles, was ihr euch jetzt über Jahre aufgebaut habt, habt ihr euch wieder eingerissen. Also diese ersten Momente waren sehr, sehr kritisch. Jetzt muss man aber auch sagen, dieses 1-0 gegen Tottenheim wurde dann logischerweise auch wieder gefeiert. Im Sinn von Schau, Milan ist wieder zumindest in Sachen Intensität, zumindest in Sachen Piss wieder da. Also es geht dann auch immer schnell. Es ist halt so wie immer, es ist halt ergebnisorientiert. Und ich glaube auch, dass Piolli, wenn er jetzt merken sollte, dass Milan wieder Selbstvertrauen findet, ich glaube auch, dass er, wenn es jetzt weiterhin in die richtige Richtung geht, auch wieder auf sein altes System zurückgreift. Aber in dem Moment war er so verunsichert, so wie die gesamte Mannschaft, dass er keinen anderen Ausweg gesehen hat, als sich wirklich erst einmal komplett von seinen Prinzipien zu verabschieden.
Ich meine, es ergibt ja auch gegen 3-4-3 eher noch Sinn, Dreierkette zu spielen. Aber es finde ich eben interessant. Ich konnte leider das Bayern-Pschä-Spiel nicht sehen, und deswegen habe ich mir auch das Milan-Tottenheim-Spiel nur in der Zusammenfassung angeguckt. Aber da haben ja die Bayern offenbar auch mit Dreierkette gespielt. Und da habe ich mir jetzt gerade die Frage gestellt, wie lief da eigentlich so die Berichterstattung dazu?
Ich finde, da kommen wir dann beim zweiten Thema nochmal. Dreierkette an sich, finde ich, man kann Dreierkette nicht per se sozusagen. Es kommt ja darauf an, wie du die Dreierkette interpretierst. Da gibt es ja zum Beispiel, gerade wenn wir uns Atalanta anschauen, du kannst es auch sehr mutig machen. Aber bei Milan war halt wirklich dieser riesen Unterschied. Also wie gesagt, falls das ein paar gesehen haben, diese erste Hefe gegen Inter, das war Wahnsinn. Sie haben nur versucht, Löcher zu stopfen, sie sind nur hinterhergelaufen, sind tief gestanden, haben all das gemacht, was sie unter Piolli jahrelang nicht gemacht haben. Aber anscheinend hat das geschafft, ihnen zu vermitteln, passt mal auf Jungs, wir schauen jetzt, dass wir über Halbwegsstabilität wieder zurückkommen und dann gehen wir wieder auf unseren alten Weg. Und Mai, jetzt zuletzt zweimal zu Null gespielt und gerade gegen Tottenheim, Champions League Achtelfinale, ja auch das erste Co-Spiel für Milan seit glaube ich neun Jahren in der Champions League. Krass!
Das stimmt mir klar, wenn man drüber nachdenkt.
Also das war jetzt schon glaube ich etwas, wieder so ein Startpunkt, um wieder zum alten Milan womöglich zurückzukommen.
Wir werden es beobachten, da sind wir mal sehr gespannt. Dann lasst uns nochmal auf La Liga blicken. Und ich weiß nicht, wie sehr ihr euch auf die Zunge bergessen musstet bei der Diskussion vorher zu den Vereinslegenden, die dann ohne große Vorerfahrung Trainer werden. Aber ich war sehr stolz auf uns alle, dass keiner von uns Schabi reingerufen hat. Warum denn? Moment, ist es denn falsch? Er ist doch eine Vereinslegende und er hatte doch keine wesentlichen Erfolge vorher.
Aber stand Barcelona kurz vorm Abstieg?
Moment, aber in der 2. Liga ist er bei 5 Vereinen gescheitert und hat nicht eine Saison zu Ende arbeiten können und wurde jeweils entlassen, weil er jeweils Misserfolg hatte. Das natürlich nicht.
Aber er kam von alles ab.
Schwierig. Wo er erfolgreich war, glaube ich, meine ich.
Okay, also ich sehe schon, ich war anscheinend der Einzige, der sich auf die Zunge gemissen hat. Ich dachte, das wäre offensichtlich gewesen. Ich dachte, ihr hättet das alles nicht gemacht, weil ihr wusstet, dass der Alex noch über Barca sprechen möchte, weil es bei denen so gut läuft.
Ja, offenbar hat sich das ja gelohnt. Also wenn da die Parallele bei Baracha dann ähnlich gut läuft, oder? Wie bei Xavi dann. Sitzen wir hier vielleicht in einem halben Jahr und loben die Anstellung von Baracha. Aber ja, mal gucken, wie es dann wird.
Aber erklär mir das mal, weil das, was bei Barcelona passiert ist, also die Ergebnisse, die haben vielleicht auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen. Sie haben jetzt eben ganz oft gewonnen und ganz oft mit 1 zu 0 gewonnen. Und das ist, finde ich, tatsächlich das, was mich überrascht und was ich auch so nicht erwartet hätte, dass eben Barcelona jetzt nach 21 Spielen 7 Gegentore hat, erst einmal verloren hat. Also das ist ja unglaublich. Und hätte ich jetzt – gut, Xavi ist natürlich auch ein strukturierdenkender Mensch, wahrscheinlich auch als Trainer. Aber was macht denn Barcelona so defensiv stark?
Verschiedenes. Zum einen der Einfluss von Xavi. Die Mannschaft arbeitet einfach viel, viel besser gegen den Ball. Das klingt so simpel und klingt fast nach, man muss den Abstiegskandidaten stabilisieren. Und wie macht man das, indem sie besser verteidigen, besser gegen den Ball spielen, gemeinschaftlicher pressen? Da sind wir fast schon wieder bei, was müsste Valencia machen? Und dann reden wir von Barca und die sind so…
Oder was macht Milan jetzt?
Also wir reden da von Barca, vom Tabellenführer von der Mannschaft, die das eine Niederlage kassiert hat, die die Supercoppa jetzt gewonnen hat im Klassik. Das klingt schon komisch, wenn du sagst, er stabilisiert erst mal die Defensive oder er stabilisiert die Mannschaft in der Arbeit gegen den Ball, aber tatsächlich, das ist Teil der Wahrheit. Die Mannschaft agiert wesentlich besser als Einheit, wenn es um Konterunterbindung gibt, wenn es um die Staffelung ist, also die taktische Staffelung gegen den Ball, wenn es um die Restverteidigung geht, wenn es auch wirklich um den Einsatz geht. Also es gab eine wunderschöne Szene. Bei Bethesda haben sie 2-1 gewonnen. Da hat Bethesda einen Konter gefahren. Früher hast du genau gewusst, dass das höchstwahrscheinlich im Gegentor resultiert, weil Konterabsicherung war seit Jahren, Jahrzehnten die Schwäche von Barca. Da werden sie immer ausgehebelt oder wurden sie immer ausgehebelt. Und plötzlich hast du gesehen, wie die halbe Mannschaft im Vollsprint zurück rennt, um diesen Konter zu unterbinden. Und obwohl ursprünglich, glaube ich, 2 Mann hinter dem Ball waren, als der Konter losging, als der Konter am 16. Barca aufhörte, waren plötzlich 7 Mann hinter dem Ball. Also sie sind wirklich im Vollsprint zurück gerannt. Und das ist ganz klar dann der Einfluss des Trainers natürlich. Also ich glaube jeder Trainer auf der Welt, wenn er diese Szene sieht, dann geht ihm das Herz auf, weil die Mannschaft Einsatz zeigt, Wille, Bereitschaften als Mannschaft zu arbeiten. Also das war wirklich sehr, sehr schön anzusehen. Aber das ist so der Hauptgrund, dass die Mannschaft wirklich einfach besser gegen den Ball arbeitet, klarer eingestellt ist, jeder kennt seine Position, jeder weiß, was er zu tun hat. Das ist der Einfluss des Trainers. Und dann natürlich, das Spielermaterial ist auch ein anderes als in den letzten Jahren. Die Abwehr wurde ja fast komplett ausgetauscht mittlerweile. Du hast ja rechts, Kunde, Jules Kunde de Valle, letztes Jahr einer der weltbesten Verteidiger, zumindest auf La Liga bezogen. Den hat Barca für, ich glaube, 50, 60 Millionen von Sevilla geholt. Der spielt jetzt als Rechtsverteidiger, ist aber eigentlich gelernter Innenverteidiger, sprich, das ist ein großer Stabilisator. Das ist nicht jemand wie Fonzie Davies, der nach vorne rennt und dann ist die ganze Seite offen. Das ist ein sehr stabiler, defensiv starker, umsichtiger Rechtsverteidiger. Der sorgt für Stabilität. Dann hast du Ronald Araucho als rechter Innenverteidiger und seinen Nebenmann Andreas Christensen von Chelsea, der ablösefrei kam und der einfach eine Top-Top-Verstärkung ist. Also allein diese drei Spieler sorgen da auch personeller Natur, individueller Natur für eine große Stabilität. Sie stehen mit ihrer individuellen Klasse für die gute Defensivarbeit Barsas.
Darf ich mal ganz kurz rein? Ich finde, man muss das echt mal hervorheben. Sieben Gegentore in 21 Spielen, das ist krass. Weil es gab in Italien, Juve hatte jetzt eine Phase, lange war Juve mit Barsas gleich auf. Juve hatte bis in Januar herein sechs Gegentore nur. Und dann sagt man klar, Juve kennt man, ist so ein bisschen in der DNA drin. Und Juve hat dafür aber acht Spiele in Folge zu Null gespielt. Also nur um das mal, jetzt ist Juve dann im Januar dann auch nach den fünf Gegentoren gegen Napoli so defensiv, hat sich das auch wieder auf einem normalen Niveau eingependelt. Aber ich finde, das muss man echt mal hervorheben. Also sieben in 21, das ist brutal.
Sie sind auf Rekordkurs. Ich habe das Ding ja noch gar nicht erwähnt, der logischerweise da auch einen Anteil hat, der auch vielleicht in der Form seines Lebens ist, zumindest so wie 2015 rum. 2014, 2015, wo er die Champions League gewann mit Barca und wo er unter anderem in München, man erinnert sich, diese Doppelparade gegen Lewandowski beim 2 zu 3, gibt es ja immer wieder auf Social Media als Highlight. Da war er in Topform. Seitdem, in den letzten Jahren, als Barca auch in der Krise war, war er nicht mehr so in der Topform und hat sie jetzt definitiv wiedergefunden. Also für mich aktuell einer der wahrscheinlich drei weltbesten Torhüter. Von der Form her sagt das auch selber. Er hat ja den Sommer frei genommen. Hat sich ja von der DFB 11 mit Hansi Flick abgesprochen, dass er da den Sommer frei hat, um da einfach mal wieder körperlich und mental durchschnaufen zu können. So hat er es selbst in verschiedenen Interviews gesagt. Und das hat ihm super, super gut getan. Und er ist auch in grandioser Form. Hat 16-mal zu Null gespielt in 21 Spielen. Das muss man sich mal vorstellen. Und ist damit auf Rekordkurs. Der Rekord in La Liga sind 26 zu Null Spiele. Aus der Saison 93, 94 von einem gewissen Francisco Liano. Den kannte ich jetzt gar nicht. Er ist ein bisschen her. Habe ich La Liga noch nicht so verfolgt. Bei Deportivo La Coruña. Und der Gegentorrekord in La Liga, der ist bei 18 Gegentoren von Athletico und auch von Deportivo. Und Barca hat ja erst 7. Also da ist die Hintermannschaft Barsas mit der Stegen als Torhüter aktuell jeweils auf Rekordkurs, was die Zahlen anbelangt.
Und ja auch durchaus interessant, dass wir hier über der Stegen sprechen, der dann ja ganz offensichtlich in einer fantastischen Form ist. Der gute Mann ist 30, ein gewisser anderer Herr, der sich beim Skifahren das Wadenbein gebrochen hat, ist ein bisschen älter und ich finde es so interessant, dass – also klar, das hat natürlich auch mit gewissen Interviews zu tun, dass wir mehr über Manuel Neuer sprechen. Aber trotzdem ist es interessant, wie Marc-Andre Ter Stegen, ganz gegensätzlich zu dem, was Uli Hoeneß mal behauptet hat, der behauptet hat, die Westpresse würde ihn in die Nationalmannschaft treiben, meiner Meinung nach genau das Gegenteil ist der Fall, dass das völlig unter dem Radar läuft, dass es da einen deutschen Torhüter gibt, der beim unangefochtenen Tabellenführer spielt mit 8 Punkten Vorsprung und wesentlicher Teil des Erfolges ist. Man muss es immer mal wieder betonen, finde ich.
Und er ist nicht so im Fokus, aber das liegt natürlich daran, dass er nicht in Deutschland spielt. Also wenn du ähnliche Zahlen, selbst bei Union Berlin sagen wir mal, wenn da ein deutscher Torhüter drin stehen würde und er hätte ähnliche Zahlen, ständig zu Null und Überflieger mit seiner Mannschaft. Komisches Beispiel, Barca mit Union vergleichen, aber mir geht es ja nur darum, dass jemand eine tolle Performance zeigt, oft zu Null spielt, wenig Gegentore und du wärst dabei in Deutschland, hättest du halt einfach einen anderen medialen Fokus. So bist du halt nur in Anführungszeichen in Spanien, auch wenn du natürlich beim mitgrößten Verein bist, einer von beiden, aber du bist ja trotzdem einfach nicht in Deutschland präsent. Und ich glaube, das spielt schon auch einfach eine Rolle.
Deswegen wird auch Kevin Trapp deutlich mehr, oder Geni ist deutlich mehr medialer Auseinandersammlung, was ich nicht ganz verstehe, weil Kevin Trapp gilt als Weltklasse, das ist für mich aber eher guter Torwart, mehr nicht. Natürlich hält er immer wieder, ich soll es sagen, bei der Frankfurter Eintracht, aber er hat immer wieder einen Zeller drin und deswegen verstehe ich den Hype um Trapp und für mich ist deswegen auch ganz klar, solange es ein neuer ausfällt, auf jeden Fall die Nummer eins jetzt, die März- und Juniländerspiele und Trapp die Klare Nummer zwei. Obwohl Lenus sich auch erheblich gesteigert hat bei Fulham und er mindestens auf gleicher Höhe mit Rat ist.
Du hast deutlich geäußert, dass Trapp eigentlich dann jetzt gerne mal die Nummer 1 werden dürfte, weil er ist ja bis jetzt der beste Deutschland-Torwart aktuell.
Mich überrascht das auch immer wieder, weil klar, er ist nicht in Deutschland, keine Frage, aber er spielt beim FC Barcelona. Das ist schon viele Jahre. Ich muss. Also für mich auch sehr, sehr erstaunlich, wie das so verstanden geht.
Wie gesagt, 16 mal zu Null spricht er schon für sich, wobei da bist du natürlich von der Abwehr abhängig. Aber viel interessanter ist ja aus Torwart-Sicht die Statistik, dass er 84 Prozent seiner Schüsse hält. Also die Safe-Percentage ist mit Abstand die Höchste in La Liga. Das heißt auch, dass wenige, was auf sein Tor kommt, hält er überproportional gut. Da ist ja jeder Wert über 80, ist ja fast schon fabelwert. Und die sehr, sehr guten Torhüter haben ja dann hohe 70er-Werte. Und das ist ja schon Weltklasse. Also Couture kommt, glaube ich, auf 74 bis 76 Prozent, was auch schon grandios ist. Aber das Ding hat einfach 10 Prozent mehr. Also auch das, wenn man ein bisschen da in die Statistiken rein sich reinwühlen möchte. Also das ist nicht nur die Zahl an sich, viele zu Nulls und eine tolle Abwehr. Da gehören auch Mitspieler dazu. Aber er hält auch wirklich herausragend, dass wenige, was auf sein Tor kommt.
Aber wirklich, das sagen auch die Post-Shot-Expected-Ghosts, die man auf beref.com finden kann. Da ist er der drittbeste Torhüter nach der Ratio zwischen denen eben, wie statistisch gesehen, wie viele Tore er hätte kassieren sollen.
Wer sind die ersten beiden, wenn ich fragen darf?
Elche und Villareal, leider kann ich da als die Torhüter Namen nicht dazu sagen.
Villareal müsste Rulli gewesen sein, der ist aber jetzt bei Ajax. Ich glaube, der hat auch recht gut gehalten, aber wurde dann verkauft entgegen des guten Trends offenbar. Und der von Elche, das ist übrigens der Tabellenletzte, die erst ein Spiel gewonnen haben. Die kriegen auch einfach im Schnitt 15 Torschüsse pro Spiel aufs Tor. Und dann muss er einfach viel halten und kann viel halten. Also das ist ja auch immer so eine Sache.
Das ist korrekt, also der hat schon 44 Tore kassiert und hätte 49 kassieren sollen. Da ist der Unterschied zwischen Marc-Andre Ter Stegen, der hätte 10, 4 Tore kassieren sollen und hat nur 7 kassiert. Also wir sehen ein anderes Niveau. Ach ja, der liebe Ter Stegen. Wir behalten ihn besser im Auge hier in der Ligatur. Und dann sind wir auch nicht überrascht, wenn er vielleicht mal sogar in der Männer-Nationalmannschaft positiv verformt. Übrigens, die letzte Niederlage Barsas war tatsächlich das 0 zu 3 gegen Bayern. Das ist das letzte Mal, dass wir Barsas quasi in der nationalen Öffentlichkeit hier hatten. Und inzwischen ist ja ein bisschen was passiert. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es aussieht. Falls ihr das schnell hört, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Am heutigen Donnerstag, dem 16. Februar findet ja das Spiel Barsas gegen United statt. Völlig logisch ist das Europa League, klingt ja auch überhaupt nicht nach Champions League von vor ein paar Jahren. Ich glaube, das kann man sich angucken. Da sind wir mal gespannt, wie viele Tore sie da kassieren. United ja auch nochmal ein anderes Thema. Aber gut, wir machen Premier League später. Lasst uns nochmal auf die Liga blicken, denn Alexi, du hattest ja vorhin schon angekündigt, wir haben die beiden Olympiques mit dabei und einem davon ging es nicht so gut. Das war Lyon und beim anderen läuft es aber so richtig gut. Du hast gesagt Marseille en feu, also Marseille on fire. Wie schön, dass ich das nicht aufs Deutsche übersetzt habe, aber gut. Was ist denn da los bei Marseille? Wir haben es ja schon vorhin mitbekommen, im Pokal zum Beispiel lief es ja gut. Da ist man noch mit dabei und PSG nicht mehr. Aber auch in der Liga ist es ja durchaus erfreulich, was Marseille so zeigt zuletzt.
Ja eigentlich, seit dem späteren Champions-League-Aus an den letzten Spieltagen der Gruppenphase gegen Kürzenheim. Anfang November läuft bei Marseille wirklich gut nur eine Niederlage und wie an diesem Barcelona hat man wenig Gegentore. Auf dem Grund, dass die Zeit der WM auch nie mehr als ein Tor gespielt wird, wäre es übergreifend. Jetzt hat man Paris Saint-Germain völlig verdient aus dem Pokal rausgeschmissen nach einer unfassbaren Partie, im Achtelfinale, in einem Hexenkessel über 60.000 Zuschauern, also da eine riesen Euphorie. Man hat das Gefühl, auch in der Liga ist was drin, nur noch 5 Punkte Rückstand auf PSG, die man auch noch entschränkt wieder in gut einer Woche in der Liga. Und vielleicht, wenn es bei Paris so weitergeht, dort läuft es auch überhaupt, wie ihr wisst, könnte Marseille im Zentralen Spitzenreiter werden auf einmal. Und diese Mannschaft hat sich einfach Stück für Stück auch richtig verstärkt, aber auch klug verstärkt auf jeder Position. Und man hat auch bekannte Spieler drin, wie Alexis Sanchez, wie der Ex-Sport der Minari, der zwar jetzt verletzt ist, aber auch bald wieder zurückkommt. Malinovski ist jetzt im Winter gekommen, zwei Ex-Bundesliga-Spieler, von denen man wartet, die können kein Fußball spielen, aber können es doch. Leo Balerdi und Thiago Lazinac trumpfen auf, auch der Ex-Hertaner Matteo Genduzi. Also man sieht, diese Mannschaften vor allem, was mir imponiert, die Bank ist für mich besser besetzt als die von Paris Saint-Germain. Das zeigt, wie beide Mannschaften sich in den letzten Monaten entwickelt haben, die eine in die richtige Richtung, die andere in der komplett falschen. Für mich der Hauptgarant für diesen Höhlenflug bei UNHCR ist nur Mitte 30, der Spanier, Pablo Longoria, macht eine gehausorgende Arbeit, ist wirklich top involviert. Ich meine, wie er sich mit dem Verein identifiziert, er hat genau verstanden, was die Kultur ist, wie wichtig dieser Verein ist in dieser ganzen Region. Marseille und die Provence sind einfach fußballverrückt, und deswegen ist das auch eine gute Nachricht, auch für die Spannung in der Liga, dass Marseille da wieder oben mitspielt, dass sich die Mannschaft etabliert und stabilisiert. Und hoffentlich haben wir bis zum Ende einen spannenden Titelkampf, aber auch für die Zukunft mittelfristig betrachtet, dass Marseille auch mal vielleicht in der Champions League weiterkommen kann aus der Probenphase und was man da beachtet bzw. erfolgt, ist schon sehr, sehr interessant und jedes Spiel ist auch attraktiv. Und der Trainer Igor Tudor der Kroate, der kritischt geoutet wurde im Saisonstart, weil er auch spaltet durch sein Verhalten, hat die Mannschaft jetzt komplett hinter sich. Sogar Spieler, die keine Rolle mehr spielen, sind wie der Kapitän in Kripa Yet und das ist sein Verdienst. Der Ausbau, ein kluger Schachzug von Longoria, diesen Tudor zu holen. Ich bin gespannt, wie weit das geht bei Olympique Marseille. Aber diese Mannschaft ist echt sehr stabil mittlerweile aufgestellt, sodass man optimistisch in die Zukunft blicken kann. Und wie gesagt, ich würde schon gerne 5 Euro darauf wetten, dass Olympique Marseille das Double holt, Pokalmeisterschaft dieses Saisons.
Aber gut, du bist ja bekannt für deine steilen Thesen. Christian, du hast vorhin kurz gezockt bei Malinowski, der von Bergamo ausgeliehen wurde. Warum?
Malinowski und Tudor? Genau, ja. Da kommen wir später drauf, weil es passt perfekt zum letzten Italien-Thema Igor Tudor. Er war ja bei Hellas, hat da großartige Arbeit geleistet. Er folgt dem Gasperini-Stil. Er ist einer, der in die Ecke rein zu verlegen ist.
Da musst du aber kurz ein bisschen was dazu sagen. Was ist der Gasperini?
Also Gasperini, der Atalanta-Trainer, der wirklich mittlerweile ein Role Model in Italien geworden ist. Danach komme ich auf Monza zu sprechen. Das ist auch einer seiner Ex-Spieler. Es sind viele Ex-Spieler von Gasperini, die mittlerweile Trainer sind und die zumindest einige Elemente von Gasperini, dieses Mutige, hat man ja von aggressiv, intensiv, athletisch, vorne zum Beispiel, weil wir die Dreierkette hier hatten, dass einer aus der Dreierkette fast immer auch aus dem Spiel heraus sich bis mit einer gegnerischen Strafform einschaltet. Und Tudor hat es in der Serie A sozusagen, diese Idee sozusagen schon von Gasperini weitergeführt. Und man sieht jetzt, dass er auch bei einem großen Verein, bei einem Traditionsverein mit einem gewissen Spielermaterial das auch umsetzen kann. Ja und Malinovski ist einer, das zeigt halt das, was Alex ja auch gesagt hat. Klar, Malinovski hat jetzt bei Atalanta nicht mehr die große Rolle gespielt, aber die Qualität von Malinovski, glaube ich, die steht außer Frage. Allein dieser Abschluss aus der Distanz, glaube ich, an den können sich einige erinnern. Also das sieht man auch, oder auch in Alexi Sanchez. Bei Sanchez, klar, da war er immer, das ist nicht mehr der Jüngste, keine Frage. Aber was der an Erfahrung mitbringt, der hat auch bei Inter noch, bevor er zu Marseille gewechselt ist, wichtige Spiele entschieden. Er hat zum Beispiel den Supercup gegen Juve vergangenes Jahr an der 120. entschieden. Also da steckt schon auch individuelle Qualität drin. Und das aber zu einer Mannschaft zu formen, glaube ich, da muss man schon auch den Trainer hervorheben.
Das klingt alles sehr gut. Jetzt war das letzte Mal, wo wahrscheinlich dann viele deutsche Fußballfans mit Marseille zu tun hatten, außerhalb der Ligatouren bei den Spielen gegen Eintracht Frankfurt, wo es ja auch zu Szenen neben den Rängen gab. Und es tut mir jetzt ein bisschen leid, weil jetzt haben wir endlich mal ein Ligue 1-Segument, wo wir nicht über Fan-Ausreitung sprechen. Aber trotzdem möchte ich einmal kurz die Nachfrage stellen, Alexi, wird das denn noch thematisiert? Gibt es da noch eine Aufarbeitung rund um das, was da passiert ist? Na, das waren doch die Raketen, die gefeuert wurden auf den Frankfurter Block.
Aber zum Frankfurter Block sind auch Raketen, die kommen nach sehr geflogen. Das hat mich wieder gewaltig, dass da immer die Marseillefelsen an den Pang angestellt werden. Und die Frankfurtsfans helfen da jetzt die Geisten der Welt. Die haben unheimlich viele Hooligans, die sorgen auch immer wieder für Unruhe. Bei jedem Auswärtsspiel in den Europapokal haben die auch Raketen dabei. Und es gibt immer wieder Probleme mit denen. Ich weiß nicht, warum man das Thema noch mal thematisieren sollte.
Ja, ich dachte deshalb, weil es gab ja da unter anderem den Fan, der getroffen wurde an der Heidschlagader, der zum Glück das alles gut überstanden hat. Aber ich hätte jetzt auch Ergebnisse offen. Ich will ja gar nicht sagen, die eine Seite trägt ein Beispiel, das andere, weil ich war nicht vor Ort. Aber wird das noch besprochen oder thematisiert? Ach, das ist ja verrückt. Ich hätte gedacht, weil es diese zum Glück gut gegangenen dramatischen Konsequenzen hatte. Wie gesagt, ich war ja nicht mit dabei.
Das Spiel ist auch besser verlaufen, weil auch der Polizei-Einsatz vorbei war in Frankfurt. Aber darüber mussten beide Seiten getrennt werden, weil die Frankfurter Fans auch gerne auf die Masche Anhänger drauf gehauen hätten. Und übrigens bei Paris gegen Bayern ist alles reibungslos verlaufen, obwohl es da auch aus Paris-Seite einige gewalttätige Fans gibt. Aber die 2000 Mischner oder 2300 haben ein schönes Abenderlebnis, nicht nur ergebnistechnisch.
Ich wollte jetzt auch gar nicht das sportlich positive Thema irgendwie noch abschwächen, aber es kam mir eben in den Sinn – und ich glaube, dass das dann auch viele Hörerinnen und Hörer sich erinnern – und sich diese Frage stellen. Aber das finde ich auf jeden Fall spannend, diesen Gasperini-Stil. Wegen mir kann er sehr gerne über Europa sich ausbreiten wie eine wunderschöne Blume, weil ich gucke nämlich gerne an. Und vielleicht passiert das auch gerade mit dem Gasperini-Stil. Jetzt haben wir schon die Brücke. Du hast es schon angesprochen, Christian. Über Monster wollen wir noch sprechen, denn bei denen läuft es auch ganz fantastisch.
Ja, und da schließt sich jetzt wirklich der Kreis. Wenn man wahrscheinlich jetzt nach außen die Frage gestellt hat, welche Mannschaft in Italien ist im neuen Jahr noch ungeschlagen, dann wäre wahrscheinlich von sehr vielen Napoli gekommen, was dementsprechend ja nicht verkehrt ist, weil Napoli wirklich zum Scudetto – ich möchte nicht sagen spaziert – aber extrem beeindruckt unterwegs ist. Aber Napoli hat eben ein Spiel gegen Inter verloren und dementsprechend ist Monza die letzte verbliebene Mannschaft, die ungeschlagen ist im neuen Kalenderjahr. Sie sind mittlerweile Zehnther und klopfen an die Europapokal-Ränge. Die meisten erinnern sich wahrscheinlich Monza Aufsteiger, Berlusconi und Gagliani dahinter – also großer Trubel. Aber sie machen jetzt wirklich nachhaltig gute Arbeit auf dem Feld. Und da schliesse ich jetzt den Kreis zum Gasperini-Stil. Da sind wir beim neuen Trainer, nämlich Raffaele Palladino. Das ist ein Ex-Spieler. Monza ist mit fünf Niederlagen in Folge gestartet. Als untypischer Aufsteiger mit viel Geld war dem zufolge der Trainer. Stropa musste gehen und sie haben Palladino hochgezogen aus der eigenen Jugend. Der hatte noch keine Profi-Erfahrung. Und zu Palladino muss man sagen, ehemaliger Serie A-Spieler, der hat schon in der Jugend unter Gasperini bei Juve gespielt, hat dann unter Gasperini bei Genoa als Spieler gespielt und in dieser Genoam-Mannschaft war auch Ivan Juric, der heute Torino trainiert, der einen ähnlichen Stil wie Gasperini spielen lässt, Thiago Motta, den viele noch kennen, aus dem Triple von Inter, der jetzt Bologna auch auf Platz 11 geführt hat, der auch in dieser Genoam-Mannschaft war. Der Co-Trainer von Juric war auch als Spieler in dieser Mannschaft und ein Verteidiger, Salvatore Bocchetti, hat auch kurzzeitig in dieser Saison Hellas trainiert. Damit will ich sagen, das sind alles Spieler, die unter Gasperini gespielt haben. Und da entwickelt sich wirklich so eine kleine Gasperini-Generation. Und gerade bei Balladino ist es wirklich frappierend. Es gibt einige Parallelen zum Atalanta-Stil. Das hat man ja vorhin schon mal kurz angerissen. Die Dreierkette, aber eine sehr mutige Dreierkette, die hochschiebt, wo immer mindestens einer aus dieser Dreierkette den Angriff mit vorne begleitet, sozusagen Überzahl schafft oder auch ganz oft einfach einen Überraschungsmoment schafft, dass die gegnerische Abwehrreihe dann sie vielleicht auf einen Spieler konzentrieren muss, den sie nicht auf dem Schirm hatten. Dadurch wird mehr Platz für die offensiven Kreativen frei. Das ist so ein bisschen das Grundprinzip. Es ist mutig, es ist spielfreudig. Und mit diesem Stil ist eben dieser Trainer, Palladiner, den davor noch keiner wirklich auf dem Schirm hatte, hat er jetzt Monza erstmal auf Platz 10 geführt. Und die sagen jetzt auch ganz offen, den ersten Teil haben wir erledigt, nämlich Richtung Abstieg dürfte nicht mehr viel passieren. Jetzt schauen wir, was nach oben geht. Also der Anspruch bei Monza, Galiani hat vor der Saison auch getönt, wir würden gerne Zehnter werden. Da haben ein paar gemeint, mal schauen, jetzt sind sie im Moment Zehnter. Und es ist eben nicht nur, weil sie große Namen haben, darf man nicht vergessen, Monza hat einen Stefano Senzi geholt, einen Ex-Interspieler, einen Caprari, einen Pessina von Atalanta, der genau diesen Stil kennt, der aktueller italienischer Nationalspieler ist. Also welcher Aufsteiger kann sich solche Leute holen? Es ist schon klar, sie sind kein typischer Aufsteiger, aber sie zeigen es jetzt auch auf dem Platz, dass eine Idee dahinter ist. Sie haben Juve zweimal in dieser Saison geschlagen, haben gegen Inter zuletzt auch gepunktet. Also Monza ist ein sehr guter Weg und Palladino ist ein sehr interessanter, junger Trainer der Sonalia.
Meine Güte, Gasperini, der Wolfgang Frank des italienischen Fußballs.
Ja, also Atalanta, wenn man sich kurze Tabelle anschaut, Atalanta ist jetzt auch mittendrin in den Kampf um die Champions League Rennen. Gasperini entwickelt auch Atalanta so ein bisschen in Nuancen weiter. Also es ist wirklich beeindruckend, dass da wirklich eine Generation heranwächst und Palladino eben einer der da ist. Auch ganz interessant, das ist nicht 1-2-1 der Gasperini-Stil. Also Atalanta ist jetzt mehr geradliniger, da kann man vielleicht ein anderes Mal drauf zu sprechen. Heulund und Luckmann, die zwei machen da vorne richtig Harval. Also sehr viel in die Tiefe, sehr viel geradlinig. Und bei Palladino ist das so ein Mix. Es sind diese intensiven, aggressiven Elemente. Aber Monza ist auch eine der Mannschaften, ich glaube, die mit dem drittmeisten Ballbesitz in der Liga. Also es ist auch ein Interesse daran, das Ganze schon auch mit Ballbesitz herauszugestalten, aber dann trotzdem eben diese mutigen Elemente. Ist echt schön anzuschauen. Und das Schöne daran, jetzt am Wochenende, was steht an? Milan gegen Monza. Monza gegen Milan. Für Gagliani und Berlusconi muss man nicht darüber reden. Ganz, ganz besonderes Spiel. Die alten Milan-Legenden, quasi Gagliani. Auch jedes war jetzt gegen Tottenheim bei Milan im Stadion, war gegen Torino in San Siro. Also für den ist San Siro immer noch die zweite Heimat. Und jetzt kommt er als gebürtiger Mann aus Monza. Monza erstmals in der Serie A. Jetzt spielen sie so eine große Rolle und jetzt kommt Milan zu Gast. Also logisch ein ganz, ganz besonderes Spiel für alle Beteiligten.
Und wie würdest du das mit so einem Schritt zurückbewerten? Also das läuft jetzt sportlich alles gut. Man kann aber auch, wenn man kritisch sein will, kann man sagen, es passt sich quasi dem Investitionsvolumen an, was man da hat. Und du hast ja schon gesagt, Monza-Aufsteiger. Was ist Monza für ein Verein? Und wie wird das auch in Italien begleitet? Wenn in Deutschland ein Zweitligist mit viel Geld und einem Medientaikun nach oben kommt, dann gäbe es auch sehr viele kritische Stimmen bestimmt. Absolut.
Das muss man immer mit betrachten. Aber ich finde es insofern interessant, dass gerade die Entscheidung – man würde sich ja erwarten, dass dann vielleicht auch auf der Trossetelle ein großer Name oder so – da sind sie jetzt wirklich einen anderen Weg gegangen, wurden auch immer wieder Parallelen zu Saki aufgezeichnet. Saki hat jetzt gemeint, er sieht sich ein bisschen in dieser Entscheidung mit Palladino wieder, weil Saki wurde damals von Balosconi auch, den kannte ja niemand, und dann hat er eine ganze Ära geprägt. Also jetzt wollen wir Palladino nicht diesen riesen Rucksack mitgeben, aber es zeigt schon, finde ich, dass sie eben jetzt weg vom Geld und weg vom Investitionsvolumen – was selbstverständlich nicht vergleichbar ist mit vielen anderen Mannschaften in dieser Region – trotzdem auch eine gewisse Idee dahinter ist. Was auch ganz spannend ist, im letzten Spiel gegen Bologna, ein Ligaspiel, stand in der Startelf neun Italiener. Also das ist für die Serie A extrem untypisch und zeigt auch, das hat Berlusconi auch schon vor ein, zwei Jahren gesagt, ich möchte eine italienische Mannschaft. Diesen Weg gehen sie halt auch. Und klar, wie gesagt, so ein Matteo Pesina, das einen Aufsteiger an einen aktuellen Nationalspieler holen kann, das ist jetzt alles andere als normal. Aber trotzdem mit italienischen Spielern, mit einem Trainer, der jetzt noch nicht den grossen Namen hat, auch an dieser Art und Weise dieses Fußballs zu arbeiten, finde ich, kann man Monza zu gut erhalten. Bei all den anderen selbstverständlichen Rahmenbedingungen, die alles andere als üblich in solchen Kategorien sind. Keine Frage. Nein, das ist so ein Feiertag für die. Auch für Gagliani. Klar haben die beide noch Milan im Herzen. Das ist ja ganz klar. Es gibt legendäre Bilder. Im Januar hat eben Monza gegen Inter gespielt. Der Ausgleich für Monza, das 2-2, viel in der Nachspielzeit. Da ist Gagliani auf dieser Tribüne ausgerastet vor Freude, wo du logisch genau gemerkt hast, für ihn gibt es etwas Schöneres als mit seinem Monza. Darf man nicht vergessen, Gagliani kommt auch aus Monza. Das ist auch wirklich ein Bezug zur Stadt da, dass du dann den ewigen Rivalen sozusagen in der Nachspielzeit eins einschenkst. Da ist auch sein ganzes Milan-Herz nochmal durchgekommen. Aber nein, die verstecken sich gar nicht. Für die ist das jetzt – Gagliani und Berlusconi sagen es ja auch immer – für uns der Idealfall wäre, Milan wird Meister und wir spielen mit Monza eine gute Saison. Also diese Verbindung ist immer noch extrem da und solange Monza sich weiterentwickelt, glaube ich, haben die auch kein Problem damit. Aber ganz klar, weil wir es hier hatten, Monza peilt schon auch mittelfristig an, da jetzt, ich will nicht sagen, ganz ganz oben anzugreifen, aber auf jeden Fall Richtung Europapokalplätze. Und auch deswegen vielleicht die Entwicklung so Richtung Atalanta ist auch kein Zufall, weil Atalanta das Ganze auch Schritt für Schritt über einige Jahre sich jetzt in eine Situation gespielt haben, dass du eigentlich mit Atalanta jedes Jahr, zumindest im Kampf um die Champions League Plätze rechnen musst. Und der Anspruch, das Ziel von Monza ist sicher auch in diese Richtung zu gehen.
Ja, ich glaube, dann werden wir noch öfter über Monza sprechen. Es ist ja auch interessant, dass es so manche Teams gibt, da spricht man dann über die Präsidenten, das haben wir jetzt auch heute in der Liga. Ja, zum Beispiel auch schon. Manchmal sprechen wir über die Sportdirektoren, manchmal über die Trainer. Das scheint auch irgendwie so ein bisschen, vielleicht auch durchaus so ein bisschen ergebnisabhängig zu sein, wie gut oder schlecht man da dann die Verantwortlichkeiten verteilt. Ich würde gerne abschließend die Frage an euch alle stellen, welches Spiel man am Wochenende verfolgen sollte. Müssen wir dann für die Serie A Monza gegen Milan einloggen? Oder lacht dich da noch was anderes Besonderes an, was wir haben?
Ja, also ist auf jeden Fall spannend, die Konstellation. Wie gesagt, auch Monza wirklich in sehr guter Form. Ich kann aber auch jedem nur am Freitag Sassuolo gegen Napoli ans Herz legen, weil was Napoli weiterhin macht, ist einfach herausragend. Und Sassuolo hat sich auch wieder gefangen, hat ihm zuletzt diese fünf Stückchen San Siro und Milan eingeschenkt. Eine sehr spielstarke Mannschaft. Bin gespannt, ob die ein Mittel gegen dieses sehr beeindruckende Napoli finden.
Freitag ist das ganz gut, weil vielleicht hat ja dann Alex kein Freitagsspiel. Alex, welches La Liga-Spiel sollten wir uns zu Gemüte führen?
Eigentlich hast du es schon genannt. Das Spiel der Spiele ist heute Abend in der Europa League und weniger in der Liga. Barca gegen Man Utd. Kommt vielleicht für den einen oder anderen Hörer zu spät, wenn ihr die Episode anhört. Dann würde ich ihm ans Herz legen, vielleicht die Woche oder dieses Wochenende eher nur so neben Beilerliga zu folgen und den richtigen Fokus dann aber nächste Woche legen. Nicht nur auf dann Man Utd. Barca mit genügend Vorlaufzeit, sondern nächste Woche ist das Madrid der Stadtderby Real Madrid gegen Atletico, also Samstag, 25.02. Das ist das Spiel. Der Spiele kann man jetzt nicht so sagen. Atletico war dafür zuletzt nicht gut genug. Aber in diesem Wochenende gibt es nicht so das Spiel Barca, zum Beispiel nur zu Hause gegen Cardis. Pflichtgemäß ist 1 zu 0, könnte es da geben. Würde ich jetzt schon sagen. Real Madrid hatten schwere Spiele und Osasuna, aber da würde ich jetzt auch nicht sagen, versammelt euch zwingend vor dem Fernseher. Vielleicht eher dann bei United oder eben die Woche drauf beim Madrid der Derby.
Okay, also ich hätte jetzt gesagt, allein von der Tabellenkonstellation her, Atletico gegen Bilbao, also gegen Atletiq Bilbao, aber...
Normalerweise von den Namen der Verein, ja, aber das kann halt auch immer ein sehr unansehnliches 0-0 werden. Da weiß man bei Atletico ja nie. Also du kannst natürlich auch da Spektakel haben, weil Atletico auch immer für verrückte Dinge steht, also irgendwie Notbremse in der 9. Minute. Dann spielen sie in Unterzahl, dann schießen sie in der 91. das 1-0 und in der 93. kassieren sie das 1-1. Auch dafür sind sie in den letzten Jahren gut, aber ob es jetzt sportlich der Leckerbissen wird, bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher. Deswegen konnte ich es nicht einfach sofort empfehlen, das Spiel.
Okay, dann lasse ich dich damit auch davon kommen und stelle abschließend noch die Frage an Alexi. Was sollten wir im Blick behalten in der Ligue 1 am Wochenende?
Ja, der Sonntag vor allem, weil um 13 Uhr haben wir Paris Saint-Germain gegen Lille. Und Paris könnte zum vierten Mal in Folge verlieren gegen eine Mannschaft, die den ansinnlichsten Fußball bietet in der Liga mit einem wieder ehemaligen Serie A-Trainer, mein lieber Christian, Paulo van Zylker, der eine tolle Arbeit macht in Nordfrankreich. Und dann wird es noch enger für Christophe Galti, der Trainer von PSG. Um 13 Uhr ist es ungefähr die Uhrzeit, wo normalerweise eine EM aufsteht. Und abends auch, von Natima Säe haben wir schon thematisiert, aber ich bin in Toulouse und diese Mannschaft könnte man nächstes Mal thematisieren bei diesem Aussteiger. Ich bin auch in einem überragenden Fußball, voll im Offensive ausgerichtet, einer der besten Angriffe der Liga. Und ich glaube, ich werde zoraus und einen schönen Sonntagabend kann man dann erleben.
Und natürlich wegen der Anschlusszeit. Das ist natürlich frech, dass dann ein Nehmer früher aufstehen muss. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Danke an Alexis Menuge. Danke an Alex Truica. Sehr gerne. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Und danke, lieber Christian Bernhard. Schön, dass du hier warst. Und wir machen an der Stelle jetzt weiter mit der Premier League. Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß dabei. Jetzt begrüße ich bei mir Jogi Hebel, die Legende. Er ist hier. Hallo Jogi, schön, dass du Zeit für die Ligatur hast.
Bei Legende bin ich jetzt fast vom Stuhl gefallen, aber gerne.
Ja, es wird ein Legendensegment. Zumindest werden wir uns mit der Premier League auseinandersetzen. Und da beginnen wir aktuell. Denn bisher war es ein Kopf-an-Kopf-Rennen zwischen Arsenal und City. Um die Tabellenführung. Arsenal war schon ein bisschen davon gekommen, aber jetzt ist am gestrigen Abend – wir nehmen am Donnerstag, den 16. Februar auf – etwas passiert, was eben dazu geführt hat, dass jetzt zumindest stand, jetzt Manchester City aktueller Tabellenführer ist und Arsenal eingeholt ist, zumindest für den Moment. Denn die beiden hatten ein Nachholspiel, und das hat City mit 3 zu 1 gewonnen. Was sind denn die Erkenntnisse aus dieser Partie?
Ja, dass Arsenal einfach noch nicht so stabil ist, wie man glaubte. Die hatten wirklich einen guten Start, aber jetzt kommt wieder diese wunderschöne Floskel. In der Saison ist das einfach ein Marathon und kein Sprint. Die sind sehr, sehr gut aus den Startlöchern gekommen, aber in den letzten Wochen hat es einfach wirklich nicht mehr gut. Das muss man klar sagen. Sie sind gegen Elberton verloren. Sie haben dann unentschieden gespielt am Wochenende gegen Brentford, auch wenn das jetzt nicht mit rechten Dingen zugegangen ist, muss man wirklich fairerweise sagen, und haben jetzt halt wieder verloren. Das sind drei Spiele, ein Stück, in den sie jetzt einfach nicht gewonnen haben. Und dann merkt man auch diese Stabilität. Ja, ein Tommy Yasu, dessen Scouting-Bericht sagt, seine größte Stärke ist, dass er keine Fehler macht. Und genau der spielt den Ball direkt auf Kevin de Boijne. Dann natürlich auch noch fälscht er den zweiten ab. Also sie waren dann einfach auch irgendwann in der zweiten Hälfte nicht mehr scharf. Und das ist dann schon etwas, mit dem ich nicht gerechnet habe, dass die so einstürzen plötzlich. Wir haben vor zwei Wochen noch die Diskussion mit einem Arsenal-Scout gehabt und mit Uli im Podcast. Uli meinte, die werden Klarmeister. Der Scout meinte, die werden Klarmeister. Ich war mir ziemlich sicher, dass City das noch machen wird, weil die haben einfach die Erfahrung. Die haben in den letzten Jahren immer wieder solche Rückstände aufgeholt, sogar in höherer Größenordnung. Und dann kommt das noch dazu, dass die natürlich psychologisch dieses Spielchen schon 100 Mal durch haben. Und die Ganners jetzt natürlich wieder in der Drucksituation sind. Das ist ja ganz klar.
Wenn ich mir jetzt – ich konnte es gestern leider nicht sehen, das Spiel, und es war ja auch interessant, dass es parallel zur Champions League angesetzt war. Deswegen muss ich mich jetzt quasi auf deine Beurteilung verlassen und habe nur die Statistiken. Aber da ist mir eben eine ins Auge gestochen. Also am Ende schießt City drei Tore, hat insgesamt neun Schüsse. Arsenal hatte nur zehn Schüsse. Aber was mich wirklich umgehauen hat, war auch in diesem Spiel. Arsenal eindeutig die Mannschaft im Ballbesitz. 64 Prozent und Manchester City, die jetzt auch nicht so ballbesitzfeindlich sind, mit 36 Prozent. War das eine taktische Maßgabe? War das ein Kniff von Pep Guardiola? Hat der Spielverlauf damit zu tun, dass in der 24. Minute es schon 1-0 für City steht? Wie würdest du das beurteilen?
Schon auch ein wenig. Aber City weiß auch, dass Arsenal, wenn man die köder, dass die einfach zu erwischen sind. Das muss man schon auch sagen. Das ist in dieser Saison immer mal wieder zu sehen gewesen. Die Ganners waren nicht schlecht, sondern sie hatten wirklich eigentlich viel Ballbesitz, hatten auch ein paar gute Phasen. Aber Adeta hat selbst gesagt, sie haben die falschen Räume bespielt, haben nicht verstanden, wo man spielen muss. Und wenn sie Chancen hatten, haben sie die einfach liegen lassen. Also entweder sie haben gar nicht abgeschlossen und dachten, sie können nochmal den Haken machen und dann den Schuss erst loswerden. Oder sie sind einfach gar nicht zum Schuss gekommen, weil einer zu spät gekommen ist. Oder dergleichen. Gerade in Ketia, da gab es sogar die Frage vom Journalisten, hätte der nicht sogar einen Head-Trick erzählen müssen. Also das ist ja das große Problem. Sie haben einfach vorne keinen, der momentan abdrückt. Gabriel Jesus fehlt, der es aber eigentlich auch nicht ist. In Ketia spielt er einfach richtig gut mit. Aber er ist einfach kein Abschlussspieler. Und selbst Zaka und Martinelli waren gestern Katastrophe. Das ist einfach das große Problem, dass sie gestern einfach nicht effizient genug waren. Und City war in der zweiten Halbzeit genau das. Es war mir einfach klar, dass wenn die aus der Pause rauskommen, dass City irgendwie – das war in den letzten Wochen immer so – die verpennen den Schlaf. Äh, die verschlafen den Startsof. Und in der zweiten Hälfte sind die dann richtig gut. Und genau so war es halt gestern auch wieder. Irgendwie hat sich es abgezeichnet, dass die dann einfach nochmal was drauflegen können und dass bei Arsenal dann eher es grübelnlos geht.
Wie ist denn so, dass Echo jetzt auf diese Schwächephase Arsenal ist und dann auch gleichzeitig da mit einhergehend ja auch eine Stärke von City, die ja auch noch ganz andere Themen haben? Also ich denke, wir müssen jetzt nicht absolut ins Detail einsteigen, weil dann sprengen wir diese Ligatour. Aber Manchester City wurde von der Liga verklagt. Kannst du da mal für diejenigen, die nur die Überschriften gelesen haben, ganz kurz sagen, um was geht es da? Und spielt das überhaupt jetzt eine Rolle, wenn jetzt über sportliche Themen bei City gerade gesprochen wird?
Okay, ich hatte sie die letzte Woche und muss schon sagen, ich glaube, dass das schon ein Faktor ist. Also sie sind in über 100 Fällen von der Premier League quasi ja angezeigt worden. Meistens Financial Fairplay. Sie haben Verträge nicht angegeben oder die Vertragsinhalte nicht angegeben oder falsch angegeben oder zu niedrig angegeben. Sei es mit Spielern, sei es mit Trainern, sei es auch mit Sponsoren. Und das natürlich dann logischerweise verschiebt es die Bilanz oder zumindest das bilanzielle Bild, dass die Premier League von diesem Verein hat und damit natürlich Financial Fairplay Regeln gebrochen. Jetzt hat die Liga schon ein bisschen zurückgerudern müssen, weil allein schon mal sechs Fälle davon nicht gerechtfertigt waren. Da hat natürlich jetzt City die Hoffnung, dass das so weitergeht, dass der eine oder andere Fall da beugtelt und das dann heißt, nee, ist nicht so. Ein Satz könnte aber wirklich zum Problem werden. Es ist der Scheich quasi gefragt worden, ob er irgendwie Geld reingepumpt hat. Er hat gesagt, nein, absolut nicht. So ist dieser Satz gewesen. Er hat quasi kein Geld über Etihad in den Verein gepumpt. So ist die Devise von ihm. Und das kann natürlich dann irgendwann mal zum Genickbruch werden, weil ich glaube, dass es – also die Engländer vermuten, dass das gelogen ist und vermuten, dass ihm das wirklich noch um die Ohren fliegt. Und jetzt muss man sich natürlich mal auf die Spieler einstellen. Ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass das Thema ist in der Mannschaft. Die werden mit Sicherheit nicht sagen, ach ist doch egal, wir spielen 100%-lich Champions League, wir werden 100%-lich Meister, weil die Punkte werden uns nicht abgezogen. Sondern ich glaube, dass das schon Thema ist, weil es ist nicht zum ersten Mal der Fall. Guardiola wird immer darauf angesprochen, Guardiola muss immer antworten, es steht überall. Ich bin mir schon sicher, dass das Thema ist und dass das mit Sicherheit ein bisschen für Unruhe sorgen wird. Dann gibt es natürlich die Geschichte mit Cancelo, Begräune, also immer wieder Ärger auch mit den Spielern oder Kritik an den Spielern. Dann nimmt er wieder mal einen raus. Es ist nicht ganz ruhig. Das, was ja eigentlich bei City immer so auf dieser retorten Insel der große Vorteil war, die hat eine Ruhe. Weil es einfach keiner irgendwie groß interessiert, dass keiner groß interessiert hat. Und das ist jetzt schon so ein bisschen raus. Das muss man schon sagen. Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass da ein bisschen mehr Druck ist als in den letzten Jahren. Trotzdem muss man halt sagen, Guardiola ist halt einfach ein klasse Trainer. Die Mannschaft ist klasse. Und gestern hat man an der Show gemerkt, die können sich dann halt irgendwann mal davon frei machen. Und haben einfach dann diese unglaubliche Klasse, das dann zu Ende zu spielen. Ich hab's gestern dem Cutter, der neben mir saß, ich muss das zusammenfassen für Sky. Schau dir das mal an, in der Bundesliga wären diese drei Tore nicht gefallen. Weil da hätte irgendjemand auch abgedreht, da hätte irgendjemand gewartet, gezögert. Die haben einfach wirklich diese Schlagfertigkeit, dann in dem Moment das sauber zu Ende zu spielen, mit dieser unglaublichen Klasse und diese Dinger rein zu machen. Und das ist wirklich einfach wahnbrechend, muss man klar sagen. Und Jack Greenlister in der Kritik stand, der macht dieses Tor als wär's nichts. Ein Haarland braucht eine Sekunde, um den Abschluss zu wählen, macht das perfekt. Und auch, schau dir das wirklich mal an, das erste Tor von de Boijne, Tome Yasso spielt den Ball zurück, und genau, de Boijne rennt da rein. 90 Prozent der Spieler, die ich kenne, hätten den entweder auf die Tribüne gehauen, oder sie hätten einfach gesagt, ach, ich schieß gar nicht erst. Der macht mit seinem schwachen linken Fuß über den Torwart drüber, in einer absoluten Klasse-Manier. Die haben halt einfach wirklich eine gute Truppe, muss man halt sagen.
Ja gut, und da greifen ja dann die beiden Themen auch ineinander, wenn man das bei Ninja Fair Play umgeht. Dann ist es auch einfacher, eine gute Gruppe zusammenzustellen, wenn man dann auch wirklich viel Geld hat. Jetzt hast du gerade Cancello und de Bruyne kurz angesprochen. Ich glaube, Cancello, das haben wir alle mitbekommen. Das war durchaus erstaunlich, dass jemand, der noch vor wenigen Jahren oder vor kurzer Zeit einer der besten Außenverteidiger der Liga war, dass der zum FC Bayern wechselt. Und das hat ja ganz offensichtlich mit dem Binnenverhältnis zu tun zwischen ihm und Pep Guardiola und vielleicht auch ihm und der Mannschaft beziehungsweise der Angst, dass da etwas abfärben könnte. Du hast De Bruyne jetzt auch noch genannt, das habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht mitbekommen. Gibt es da ein ähnliches Thema?
Ja, also der hat ihn mal angezählt, ich glaube nach dem Brighton-Spiel, also vor dem Brighton-Spiel glaube ich, da hat er gesagt, dass ihm die eine oder andere Einstellung nicht gefällt und dass deswegen auch der eine oder andere Spieler mal nicht spielt. Da war wohl De Bruyne gemeint. Und dann hat er ihn ja in den beiden Totten im Spielen, die ja jetzt vor diesem Arsene-Spiel nicht unwichtiger waren, um eben zurückzukommen, da hat er ihn auch auf die Bank gesetzt und in einem Spiel sogar 90 Minuten auf der Bank sitzen lassen. Und das ist natürlich dann schon etwas, wo viele gesagt haben, okay, also Kevin De Bruyne in so einem wichtigen Spiel 90 Minuten auf der Bank sitzen zu lassen, ist schon ein Zeichen. Und da war eben wohl so, dass der Tenor, dass er nicht genug nach hinten gearbeitet hat, dass ihm die Einstellung nicht so gefallen hat und dass er deswegen mal ein Zeichen setzen wollte. Und er hat es auch immer wieder gesagt eben, dass De Bruyne hier schon wichtig ist, aber dass ihm momentan halt das nicht so gefällt, wie er arbeitet.
Wir werden es im Blick behalten. Ich meine, der große Unterschied zwischen Arsenal und City ist auch die Spielbelastung in den kommenden Wochen. Also City spielt ja unter anderem in der Champions League bei Rasenbeilsport Leipzig und wird ja dann eventuell noch weiter vertreten sein in diesem Wettbewerb. Und im FA Cup ist man auch noch mit dabei, während Arsenal sich auf die Liga konzentrieren darf, Schreckstrich muss und dann eben versuchen kann, diese Serie, die jetzt vier Spiele umfasst, in denen man dreimal verloren hat und einmal unentschieden gespielt hat, irgendwie zu drehen. Ich bin sehr gespannt, was sich da noch entwickelt. Da sind wir uns wahrscheinlich einig. Gibt es noch etwas zu Arsenal zu sagen, was dir auf dem Herzen liegt, bevor wir mit dem nächsten Thema weitermachen?
Ich glaube, dass Arsenal jetzt schon ein psychologisches Problem hat. Du hast jetzt verloren dieses direkte Duell. Du bist jetzt punktgleich. Ja, du hast ein Spiel weniger. Aber man muss schon sagen, du bist jetzt plötzlich vom Gejagten zum Jäger geworden irgendwo im Kopf, glaube ich. Und jetzt den Kopf nochmal hochzufahren und zu sagen, okay, wir starten das jetzt alles nochmal in diesem Moment der Enttäuschung, wo du ja eher im Kopf hast, ich glaube, das war es. Das ist jetzt die Schwierigkeit. Also wenn diese junge Mannschaft das hinbekommt, Respekt. Aber einfach, glaube ich, ist das nicht. Jetzt nochmal zu sagen, okay, wir waren ganz oben. Jetzt sind wir eingeholt worden. Jetzt muss man nochmal anfangen. Jetzt werden wir es nochmal allen zeigen. Das ist das Teil der Champions aus. Das ist genau das, was City eigentlich gemacht hat. Und jetzt ist die Frage, ob Arsenal das auch schon im Kreuz hat, wirklich zu sagen, in dieser Phase jetzt erst recht. Das ist wirklich jetzt die absolute Königsdisziplin. Und das ist die jüngste Mannschaft der Liga. Sie das können, ist die Frage. Ich sage nicht, dass sie es nicht können, aber jetzt wird sich wirklich die schöne Spreu von Weizen drin.
Und gleichzeitig muss man sagen, dieser Nachholtermin, das war ja, glaube ich, wegen des Tods der Queen, das dieses Spiel verschoben wurde. Das ist natürlich nochmal so ein zusätzlicher, naja, das macht es einfach für die Fans schwer verdaulich, weil man schon die These aufstellen kann, bleibt dann immer eine Hypothese, kann man nicht überprüfen, dass man damals, hätte das Spiel damals stattgefunden, vielleicht bessere Chancen gehabt hätte, als jetzt, wo man eben aus einer Schwächephase kommend eben schon gegen City spielen musste. Aber so ist es eben manchmal. Wir wollen noch über den FC Southampton sprechen und für alle Hörerinnen und Hörer, die sich wundern, warum kommt jetzt hier Southampton? Naja, das könnte unter anderem mit dem Tabellenplatz zusammenhängen, denn die liegen auf dem allerletzten Platz, haben nur 15 Punkte. Für vier Punkte Rückstand sind es auf Leeds United, die aktuell auf dem ersten Nicht-Abstiegsplatz liegen. Was ist bei Southampton los?
Ich habe den Trainer entlassen, Nathan Jones, und dann war es eben so gut wie sicher, dass eigentlich Jesse Marsh der neue Trainer wird, der bei Leeds erst wenige Tage zuvor entlassen worden ist, der ehemalige RB-Trainer. Und der wird es jetzt offensichtlich nicht. Knackpunkt ist scheinbar die Vertragslänge, was man so liest. Aber es ist halt sehr kurios, weil auf Hasen Rüttel, der ja eigentlich ein gestandener Trainer war weltweit, einen Trainer geruht hat, der mit Nathan Jones, der ein besserer Zweitliga-Trainer war, der bei Stoke es nicht geschafft hat, irgendwie etwas hinzubekommen und eigentlich nur in Looten funktioniert hat. Und der dann halt am Schluss sehr krude und sehr wirre Interviews gegeben hat mit Aussagen wie, ich bin nicht schuld, sondern im Endeffekt durfte ich ja nicht ich selbst sein und ich war ein anderer und musste ein anderer sein, aber jetzt werde ich wieder ich selbst sein. Und dann, als er selbst war, lief es noch viel schlimmer. Und dann auch letztendlich gedroppt hat, wie ich bin statistisch gesehen der beste Trainer Europas. Wo man sich halt wirklich die Frage stellt, was ist denn eigentlich mit dem los? Und Uli kam eigentlich, der hatte jetzt auf dem ein paar Mal, der kam jedes Mal raus und kam zu mir und sagte, ey, was der schon wieder für Interviews gegeben hat, du musst dir das mal anhören. Weil der einfach komplett neben der Spur ist. Und so hat die Mannschaft auch gespielt. Und das große Problem ist halt, nach dieser Hasenütterentlassung, wo du ja eigentlich gewusst hast, es geht runter in der Tabelle, dass du dann halt sagst, wir gönnen uns ein Projekt, bei dem wir nicht wissen, ob der schon dieses Premier League Format hat. Damit hast du jetzt einfach halt einen Monat, glaube ich, war er jetzt im Amt, oder ich weiß keine wie viele Monate, das hast du einfach verloren. Das hast du einfach verloren. So easy ist es. Seit November, gut, 14 Spiele. Du hast einfach Zeit verloren. Du musst jetzt wieder von vorn anfangen, jemanden zu finden, der dir hilft. Und da ist das große Problem einfach, Southampton hat da, glaube ich, die Situation nicht ganz richtig verstanden, und sind jetzt tabellnetzter.
Und dann ist es ja auch einigermaßen skurril, deswegen habe ich nämlich extra den Abstand Solic United nochmal genannt, dass man dann eben denjenigen Premier holen möchte im ersten Versuch, der da gerade entlassen wurde. Hängt das damit zusammen, dass eben sowohl Jesse Marsch als auch Ralf Hasenhüttl eben aus der viel beachteten Red Bull-Familie kommen? Ich habe jetzt ehrlicherweise von den letzten Spielen nicht mehr verfolgt, deswegen weiß ich nicht, wie umschaltlastig das noch war und wie pressinglastig und so weiter. Also geht es da quasi darum, oder wie ist man auf den Gedanken gekommen, dass jemand, der bei einem anderen Verein, der direkte Abstiegskonkurrent ist, nicht funktioniert hat, auf einmal die Lösung für Southampton sein könnte?
Ja, wahrscheinlich. Ich glaube, das Narrativ war, um Marsch immer so quasi, naja, es sah ja gut aus, sie haben sich einfach nur nicht belohnt. Und ich weiß schon auch, dass aus erster Hand, dass in Southampton neue Bosse quasi dran sind oder zumindest ein neuer Sportdirektor und dass dort einfach schon ein bisschen progressiver gearbeitet werden soll. Das ist so dieses Ding. Und Jesse Marsch passt natürlich schon irgendwo hin, weil, wie du eben gesagt hast, Hasenlüttel ließ ja auch so ein Umschaltfußball spielen. Sehr intensiv drauf. Die Mannschaft ist schon so ein wenig darauf ausgerichtet. Das könnte schon funktionieren. Bei Lieds war es halt so, dass die sich einfach nicht belohnt haben. Das muss man schon sagen. Aber auch da hat uns ein anderer Scout, nicht der, sondern der hat uns gesagt, das kannst du dir oder das konntest du dir am Schluss nicht mehr ansehen. Du kriegst Kopfschmerzen, weil es eigentlich nur intensives Draufrumpeln war. Und wenn die den Ball gewonnen haben, hatten die null Plan. Weil sie dann einfach gesagt haben, okay, jetzt müssen wir eigentlich was damit anfangen, was Kreatives. Und es hat nichts mehr mit Intensität zu tun, sondern mit Kreativität. Und das haben sie überhaupt nicht hinbekommen.
Und kannst du noch kurz was zum Club Southampton sagen? Was würde das für die Premier League bedeuten, wenn Southampton wieder absteigt, muss man dazu sagen? Also Southampton ist ein Urgestein, war nicht komplett seit der Gründung. Der First Division dabei. Aber im Grunde ab dann, dann auch immer in der Premier League. Und dann gab es eben schon einmal diese Phase 2005, 2006, bis eben dann 2012, in der man in der zweiten Liga war. Das heißt, wir reden hier von einem Traditionsclub.
Ja, das ist ein absoluter Traditionsverein. Und natürlich würde der fehlen. Aber man muss halt schon sagen, dass natürlich die anderen Vereine, das ist so ein bisschen wie in der Bundesliga vergleichbar, dass sie natürlich schon ein wenig da an Boden verlieren, weil dann andere Clubs mehr Geld zur Verfügung haben. Das ist so wirklich so ein Phänomen aller Bundesliga-Traditionsverein, der halt verhältnismäßig normale Mittel hat. Wahrscheinlich für Bundesliga-Verhältnisse wäre es immer noch viel. Aber der verhältnismäßig normale Mittel hat. Und plötzlich kommen dann halt welche von links und rechts und investieren da mal mehr und investieren da mal mehr. Und das ist natürlich schon das große Problem, dass sie sich da halt sehen. Arsene Lütl hat immer gesagt, wir müssen so in der Range 10 bis 15 Millionen Euro verpflichten, weil wir haben einfach keine andere Chance. Und wir können auch keines aus England holen, sondern wir müssen nach Frankreich, Niederlande und dergleichen, weil nur dort für uns ein funktionierender Markt entstanden ist. Und das sieht man ja schon. Also ich glaube, dass die meisten Premier-Ligisten da nicht dran denken, zu sagen, wir gehen jetzt nur nach Frankreich und holen da Spieler, weil wir es jetzt leisten können. Die sind schon ein wenig abgeschlagen, das muss man schon sagen. Das ist alles so ein bisschen grau geworden mittlerweile. Aber hatten halt das Glück, dass sie durch Hasenwürttel und den Fußball immer mal wieder irgendwo ein Dreier oder ein Pünktchen geholt haben. Das war manchmal auch Drama. Die sind manchmal auch untergegangen. Diese 2-mal mit neuen Gegentoren, werdet ihr alle wissen. Das konnte auch passieren. Aber im Grunde genommen gab es immer noch genug Spiele, wo sie Punkte holen konnten, weil sie dann einfach mal wieder einfach richtig nervig waren. Auch gegen City zum Beispiel habe ich mal ein Spiel gehabt, wo sie dann auch gewonnen haben. Das gab es schon auch mal, dass die die Großen geärgert haben. Das hat sich dann immer so ein bisschen gerettet. Aber wenn du natürlich da jetzt aktuell, sieht es halt wirklich sehr planlos aus. Und alles auf junge Spieler getrimmt, ist ja okay. Kann funktionieren, ist eben eine Basis. Aber dann brauchen die halt einen Konstrukt. Und wenn da mit Nathan Jones einer ist, der einfach die Liga nicht verstanden hat, der dann auch wirklich wirr daherkommt, dann verstreicht Zeit und du holst keine Punkte. Und das kannst du dir halt dann einfach da unten nicht erlauben.
Gut, wir werden es beobachten, wie es weitergeht bei Southampton. Jetzt habe ich allen bisherigen Gästen dieselbe Frage gestellt. Die bekommst auch du zum Abschluss, lieber Jogi. Welches Spiel an diesem Wochenende sollten wir denn unbedingt mitverfolgen? Und du darfst jetzt nicht mit United gegen Barca heute Abend antworten. Das hat nämlich Alex Truica schon gemacht.
Ich kommentiere Aston Villa gegen Arsenal. Bin ich sehr gespannt, bin ich wirklich sehr gespannt, wie Arsenal jetzt reagiert. Das interessiert mich sehr. Newcastle gegen Liverpool ist interessant, weil natürlich das da oben so ein Duell ist. Newcastle kann denen schon richtig Ärger machen. Selbig ist es Tottenham gegen West Ham, das kommentiere ich auch am Sonntag. Das interessiert mich auch sehr, weil man schon sagen muss, dass Tottenham jetzt verloren ist gegen Leicester, die richtig untergegangen sind. Und wie es da mit Antonio Conte weitergeht, dessen Mundwinkel immer weiter nach unten geht, bei dem ich mir ziemlich sicher bin, dass er nach der Saison hinschmeißen wird, das interessiert mich auch, wie es da weitergeht. Es sind ein paar Duellen, aber auf Arsenal und El Esten Villa freue ich mich besonders, weil ich will die Reaktionen sehen. Ich bin echt gespannt, ob meine Theorie, dass die gegen El Esten Villa jetzt schon einen drauf kriegen und da jetzt schon einen brechen, bin gespannt, ob ich recht habe oder ob ich unrecht habe. Ich würde mir wünschen, dass ich unrecht habe, weil dann bleibt es spannend.
Dann bleibt es spannend. Wir werden es sehen können am 18. Februar. Das ist der Samstag. Es ist das frühe Spiel. 13.30 Uhr dann Anpfiff. Jogi, ich danke dir ganz herzlich. Wie immer der Hinweis. Ihr könnt natürlich auch im eigenen Podcast von Jogi und Uli das genauer hören. Plus eben, da bekommt man auch Arsenal-Scouts zu hören, was jetzt auch ein bisschen untypisch ist für viele Podcasts. Ich danke dir, dass du hier mit dabei warst.
Immer wieder gerne für dich.
Das freut mich zu hören und ich danke dann auch nochmal stellvertretend Alex Truica, Christian Bernhard und Alexis Menuge und stellvertretend eben auch für alle anderen, die immer in der Ligatur mitmachen. Und ich danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern, dass ihr der Ligatur treu bleibt und dass ihr den Rasenfunk unterstützt. Tut das bitte, denn so können wir wachsen. Und dann gibt es auch solche Formate, die gibt es wirklich öfter, wenn der Rasenfunk ein bisschen wachsen kann. Ihr werdet in den nächsten Wochen hoffentlich merken, wie ich das gemeint habe. Ich möchte es noch nicht verraten, denn hinterher klappt es nicht. Ansonsten habt eine gute Zeit und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut.